there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey you guys it's Wednesday and it's the
main show thank you very much Jeffy art
already like right out the gate damn
sitting in this damn flash balls
[Laughter]
I like money yeah that's from idiocracy
if you guys ever seen that you like
money oh I like money too I kind of feel
like everybody knows that that's that's
become a meme then later on he's like
man I can't believe you like money
like he becomes his best friend
well you know
yeah all right so I'm trying to wake up
you guys yeah pookie I just poured the
drinks woke me up at 5 30 this morning
doing her Buffalo herding yeah she can
run across the floor it sounds like a
[ __ ] I heard of Buffalo for such a tiny
cat she is really really very annoying
through the whole [ __ ] house so 5 30
I'm like woke up like
yeah
she's like read it back and forth like
at all and Tom said she goes in the
living room up here on the second floor
and like runs and jumps up on the chair
and then jumps up on this little wall
ledge we got a little [ __ ] little
partition between two yeah between the
hall and like the living room yeah and
then she jumps off of that and then like
runs down the stairs and then back up
the stairs yeah yeah the whole house is
a roller coaster
and she's happy and then she'll run up
and you know if I'm sleeping there
she'll run look at you you see what I
did yeah yeah you ran through the whole
house big deal okay I'll time you next
time yeah that's something and that's
sometimes when she's doing it you can
hear her go yeah making trails and [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] hilarious yeah she's the
weirdest she's the weirdest guy ever
weirdest cat ever but yeah she woke me
up at 5 30. so
I'm super super sleepy so what's what's
today's show gonna be about we're
talking about the Acid Bath murderer yep
John George Hague yeah this guy I've
been wanting to do a show about this
[ __ ] since I read a book about
this guy when I was a kid when I was
probably too young to be reading a book
about this [ __ ] and something
about it stuck with me I guess it's the
whole thing about dissolving bodies and
sulfuric acid and I was just like
horrified but also intrigued uh so I
think it was I can't remember if it was
like a whole book about him or it might
have been I remember it being a
paperback or it might have been like
several like True Crimes like in one
book but for whatever reason that one
like really stuck with me so I've been
wanting to like do it do a show about
this yeah there were several times kind
of Acid Bath guys Dahmer was an acid
bath guy
um but I think for different reasons he
was trying to get bones
but um yeah which exact one is this is a
British Acid Bath guy yeah there was a
French one too which I'll talk I'll
mention him a little bit because that
because this guy was inspired by the
French guy
but this guy is probably I mean I think
this guy's the most famous one because
that was kind of like his whole thing
was like an acid bath thing and he's
also one of those [ __ ] you know
you know like we've talked about this a
lot on some of the True Crime shows
where it's just kind of like you know
that kind of [ __ ] that it's like
not it's bad enough that he's a serial
killer but he also he's like really
arrogant and thinks he's like smarter
than everybody and that he's gonna get
away with it yeah this is one of those
[ __ ] which yeah maybe that's
once what
yeah like what one of those ones that
think they're like super super clever
and they're gonna like outwit everybody
and everybody's like um you're kind of
stupid actually yeah like you do like
really stupid [ __ ] uh they had a damn
YouTube videos made by one of these
I don't remember what it was one of
these little outfits and they uh
it took like six College
students and uh had them all tell tell
the camera uh how smart they were and
what their IQ would be and then they had
them rank all the other people to see
how accurate they were yeah and uh the
girl at the bottom thought she was the
smartest
well she thought that the dude that was
the smartest one she thought that he was
the dumbest it just it's just well we
talked about this before but probably we
should do a whole show about done in
Kruger syndrome because the thing about
it is that sometimes like the Dumber you
are the more the smarter you think you
are because you don't know how much you
don't know does that make any sense yeah
yeah you don't realize like how much
there is that you don't know whereas
actual smart people are like holy [ __ ]
like yeah maybe I'm kind of smart but
there's like [ __ ] tons of stuff I don't
know so they're kind of more humble
about it yeah you know what I mean so
it's kind of like a weird yeah and then
the people that made the video showed
their actual IQ test scores intelligent
question scores I guess it was called
isn't that isn't that what Q stands for
anyway
and uh the the girl was a midwit not
dumb she was just like 110 like average
110 a little bit above average that is a
little bit and they noticed that right
about 100 is average but they noticed
that if you're a little bit above
average like mid width what they called
it you tend to think you're a lot
smarter than you are and then you 10
they tend to think that people that are
smarter than them must be dumber than
them because they can't understand what
they're talking about well yeah that's
another thing you're right yeah right so
got to be careful for midwoods mid-wits
are [ __ ] more damaging than people
that are below IQ because a lot of
people who are below IQ uh just kind of
just have practical knowledge they just
well I've seen this work this will work
they don't they're not worried about
status too much and
they just kind of more into practical
[ __ ] that works you know what they saw
work and what what people taught them to
do they just do that and if that works
then that's what they stick with which
they tend to
keep themselves out of trouble they'll
keep you out of trouble because they
won't make snap judgments on you they're
not really worried about you they're
worried about getting paycheck getting
food
you know which more admirable if you ask
me you know the midwit
yeah this guy I feel like is kind of
like that yeah Midway they're over Rich
overreaching trying to be more than what
they are yeah xana does she said I was
recently doing research on this guy he
was kind of unique but also a [ __ ] yeah
yeah
he was like I said he was kind of a
[ __ ] that that thought he was like
super smart which is like which is funny
but I mean it's not funny because like a
bunch of people got killed but you know
what I mean uh Zach said you guys have
got me started on a De Palma binge just
finished Raising Cane this afternoon you
know I just re-watched Raising Cane
probably like a year ago and yeah that
was like way more uh what's the word I'm
looking for a lot a lot more like
overwrought than I remembered yeah I
can't decide if I really really like it
or if it's really really bad I never
seen that one yeah John Lithgow is in it
I thought well John Lithgow works with
uh Brian De Palma a lot actually because
he was also in uh blowout now that I
mentioned it uh Alice in Wonderland says
hi Tom and Jenny I'm a long time viewer
but this is my first time on the live
chat oh my god well hey welcome a live
chat version where you live love YouTube
everything thank you thank you what she
said she said that wig is everything
okay this is my very favorite wig I have
two jerseys first live stream you must
live on the other side down plan most
people from Australia or something maybe
they're usually some that's what I was
really like well I was we wanted to
[ __ ] for a second I was confused
because Rebecca came on and she was like
it's freezing cold and I was like
freezing cold and I was like oh yeah she
lives in Australia yeah their seasons
are opposite I'm like that must be so so
[ __ ] weird like obviously it's not
weird for Australians because they grew
up like that in Brazil but yeah like for
me I'm just kind of like
I don't know it's not that weird because
I grew up in Florida and like it's all
it's pretty much always hot here at
Christmas so I get that but
I don't know it would be weird being
like cold in the in the not hot in
Christmas it's just not cold it's just
not cold yeah that's what I mean 70s I
used to 60s yeah and you get the 40s 50s
the 40s yeah sometimes but not usually
right usually usually like it'll be
January and uh once uh this is about 10
years ago it snowed here for Christmas
that was a trip I don't think it was
Christmas it's 2008. it wasn't for it
was Christmas time all the Christmas
lights were out I remember looking at
them yeah but I think it was January
like every time I've heard of it snowing
before it was before Christmas had
happened it's usually in January it was
before sometimes February it was 2008. I
remember the year 2008 that happened
yeah some well it snows every now and
then like in the middle part like in
Ocala and stuff yeah that's where it was
yeah see not usually in Eustace Ocala
era area yeah so I must have still been
in I was still in Daytona it didn't snow
over there it doesn't snow much over
there because of the um it's right on
there you know Longwood they had a whole
light display out there who drove
through it but the girl that was dating
at the time and it was [ __ ] that's
when I was dating a girl named Ashley
you never met Ashley Ashley love I got
pictures of her I'll show you she wasn't
really part of the scene
and and me and Ashley went down through
there and toured the uh the light
display the Christmas light display and
there was snow everywhere and she had
never she's from here she had never seen
snow yeah I didn't see snow until I was
in my 20s Yeah well yeah that's what she
was in she was she was uh 25 Maybe
like a 20 by 26. but she had never seen
snow
um which for Florida girls not that's
not usual that's not weird like I said
it's I didn't I I never saw snow until I
went to the UK
in
1995 or something yeah and it snowed
like I went there in January
um Camp guy said I watched a 45 minute
documentary on this dude last night he's
a real weirdo but he looks so totally
regular yeah he just looks like which is
maybe how he got away with [ __ ] he's one
of those guys
he's a serial killer in the sense that
you know he killed a lot of people six
that they know of but they suspect it's
probably more
but because of the motives
it's not like it didn't seem like a
sexual motive now I will say that he
tried later on to say that he did some
weird [ __ ] like drank blood and
everything like that but I'm not sure if
I buy that because I think he had an
ulterior motive
he was kind of more one of those
goal-oriented [ __ ] yeah like
you know what I mean directed violence
yeah so I think it was more that I don't
think he was like getting off on it so
much as just this is an obstacle that I
need to move aside so I would say H.H
Holmes was like that but I kind of doubt
it I think this is a kind of an HH
Holmes and yeah Zana just said the same
thing this guy was H.H Holmes with none
of the intelligence yeah pretty much
similar it's a similar kind of dude he's
like he starts out like doing like fraud
uh you know and then is like well I
could do fraud easier if like all these
people stopped like calling the cops on
me so I guess I'll kill him I I think
H.H Holmes though
he was goal directed but I think there
was a sexual element to to a lot of what
he was doing too
um
it's just that I think based on H.H
Holmes
what was written about him I have a
feeling he was into little boys
um but he was killing women for their
skeletons and for money and
they were easier targets remember he
always had this thing where there's
always little children around him and he
got busted for hanging out with that boy
then they accused him of having some
kind of inappropriate relationship with
this boy he was what 12.
12 or think I think so maybe 11.
I think that's what he was really after
so for all we know he was H.H Holmes was
trying to build his Empire to impress
little boys one day maybe
meanwhile little boys are like there's
no Legos or dinosaurs involved in this I
don't care yeah
Hugo said masters of horror has one
episode family oh I remember that one
with George went from cheers uh the Acid
Bath scene is pretty good that was
actually one of my favorite episodes of
Masters of Horror I think because it
reminded me of and this is going way
obscure but there was a story by Miriam
Allen De Ford I think from the 40s like
a short story that was kind of about
this guy that owned a funeral home
and he was real lonely so when he found
like a particularly Choice uh body that
came through his thing he would like fix
it all up and put it down in his uh you
know in his sitting room and he would
pose them and he would talk to him like
they were his real family and stuff hold
on who is this it was a story uh okay it
wasn't a real person then no okay he
missed part of it I was thinking it you
know
[Laughter]
yeah because he well no because he was
talking about masters of horror the
masters of horror episode and I said
well that's right that's fiction yeah
and to me it's like I didn't know see I
didn't know that was you know what I
mean I I forgotten that that's a
fictional program yeah yeah okay because
remember you like some of the episodes
of that you just rewatched it I thought
like not too long ago yeah but um yeah
that was like the whole thing I thought
that maybe that episode of Masters of
Horror was maybe Loosely based on that
short story because it was similar it
wasn't exactly the same but it did
remind me of that but that story I first
read it in one of those Alfred Hitchcock
uh you know Alfred Hitchcock Presents so
I think it was stories that scared even
me or something like that I think it was
in there
um Alice in Wonderland said hi I'm from
Queens New York thanks for saying hi
well hey it's very very nice good that
you were able to I forgive you I'll
forgive you what's wrong with it
never cooler than people from Boston
every time I went to New York the people
[ __ ] New York were tougher I liked
them you know tougher the Boston people
were a bunch of [ __ ] most of them
but it's a class system you know
the ones that were actually from there
they were a lot better the Boston people
up in the Northeast had fun there good
Winters
Senator said I grew up in Minnesota we
had a blizzard on Halloween once it
didn't stop a single kid from
trick-or-treating yeah see that blew my
mind when I was a kid because it never
ever ever ever gets cold in Florida
before December and usually not even
then so Halloween is always hot
and if you want to like wear in a really
elaborate costume I remember like being
a kid and like we'd go out for a little
while trick-or-treating and then we'd
have to come home and like change into
another costume because that one was
like all sweaty and like we were all
uncomfortable so it's like I used to see
movies sometimes where like that we're
set up north or something and like
they'd go out trick-or-treating it was
all cold and I'm like man that looks so
cool like down here we're just like
sweating our [ __ ] balls David showed
up what's up Parker
hey what's up
see oh I got like way way behind yeah
Xander said it was never clear to me if
the blood drinking actually happened
yeah I kind of doubt it I kind of doubt
it um I think that was one of the things
he pulled out his ass when he was trying
to be like
hey I'm crazy you know what I mean
because yeah we'll get into that we'll
get into that okay well I guess we can
start on the case yeah okay America have
anything anything shout out to anybody
or anything do we no okay American
Military 100 said I've been waiting ages
for 13 o'clock to survey this case so
excited okay good well I'm glad
everybody's excited but like I said I'm
excited because I wrote I read a book
about I read a book about this guy like
a long time ago when I was a kid and
I've always found him like really
fascinating in an HH Holmes kind of way
just because
and like I said I'm also kind of
fascinated by the fact that he was like
kind of a stupid [ __ ] that
thought he was really smart
like instead of Midway like in some of
the beliefs that he had yeah I don't
know it's just I don't I thought it was
like amusing you know what I mean I mean
it's not a music because people got
killed but it's still like amusing that
he thought he was gonna get away with it
that's like for really stupid reasons I
subscribe to some of the really good
science programs you know like [ __ ]
with uh Lex Friedman he's good Event
Horizon and they'll have a bunch of
Scholars and scientists on their
different different types you know from
cosmologists physicists and they'll talk
for hours on there and you'll always
notice Avi Loeb actually has a really
good analysis of scholarly types he says
a lot of it is it's a scene and a lot of
it is about status
you can tell the real smart
[ __ ] you know what I mean
by the if you ask them a question they
will say I don't know
okay they sit with unabashedly they'll
say I don't know a guy who's smart but
he's not that smart he'll try to he
doesn't want to say I don't know because
he didn't want to look bad in front of
his friends
so he tries to invent weasel his way
around saying I don't know
the whole thing about science is to know
that you don't know
you know that's part part of the
scientific process of trying to discover
the truth a lot of times what you
believe is truth change is because you
get new evidence so you don't get stuck
you can't you can't get yourself stuck
into into a real concrete beliefs all
the time things change
you know new parts of the puzzle appear
so truth is always kind of temporary
when it comes to science and there's a
lot of [ __ ] they don't know I mean not
necessarily temporary but provisional I
mean it doesn't like it doesn't usually
just like change wholesale it's usually
just you know it kind of changes
piecemeal a little bit usually because
things are like built on Well it can't
it can but it does it doesn't usually uh
some of the stuff that they're fighting
with now if it's true they vote then
everything's wrong like there's one
group of physicist physicists that think
that maybe time space is an illusion
that it's not a reality and that would
[ __ ] change everything
that places and time that time the time
stream and places is a figment of our
imagination based upon the senses that
we that we evolved with that's [ __ ]
weird and then there's some
mathematical stuff that seems to things
that happen in quantum physics that seem
to uh indicate that like how an object
can be in two places at once that's not
possible
and how uh an object like a little
subatomic particle can be in kind of
like a general area not in a single area
and it has to do with we're judging the
universe based upon our five senses
and with a human brain we're not really
seeing the universe as it really is and
space-time may not be that real and if
that happens Everything Changes
which explains a lot of the weird [ __ ]
you know that they kind of see
you know in terms of [ __ ]
supposed alien spacecraft and subatomic
particles and paranormal type stuff that
seems to happen and consciousness
the effects of Consciousness on things
and why the hell why the hell is most of
the matter dark matter in the universe
all kinds of stuff
guys says David Parker Ray the toy box
killer out of uh did we do a show about
him if not he's in I know I put him in
the poll before if we haven't done a
show about it and Oscar said I've been
waiting ages for 13 o'clock to do the El
pass at Walmart shooting that's another
one that I put it in the poll a couple
times and it didn't win but I keep you
know I have like a big list and I keep
like rotating them out So eventually
like we'll get to all of them probably
uh Camp guy says great book The Dancing
woolly Masters yeah I read that uh
explains macro and quantum physics in
everyday terms or language yeah that
actually was a really good book I might
have it in here somewhere now that I'm
thinking about it see one of the
problems some of these guys talk about
is that everything that modern science
and physics is expressed in mathematics
and uh we're we're
these scientists have all been raised
with the background of believing that
mathemat that everything can be that
meant that everything can be described
as some kind of a mathematical
expression when uh no probably not some
guys are saying it's probably some kind
of damn wave forms and that mathematics
is a totally human construct
which would change everything we're just
interpreting it in a mathematical way
but that that's that it's not actually
what it is it's a lot more um it's not
digital what they're saying they're
saying it's analog which that's and it's
obvious that it's analog you're just
using mathematics to describe an analog
process
uh
which is only capturing a certain
aspects of what we would call reality
there's a lot more to it than that
not as predictable
all right so are we ready to get on with
the assets
let's go let's do this [ __ ] this was
actually like a good one to pick today
because this was one that I kind of
already knew a lot about and it's not
super complicated you know what I mean
it wasn't one of those ones where I was
like Hey five different cases that I had
to like research and all this other kind
of stuff so it was like much easier
so John George Hague
now he was born in 1909 like I said he
was born in uh this is a British guy he
was born in Lincolnshire but uh he moved
to West Yorkshire later on when he was a
kid and then spent a great deal of time
there
now the household he was brought up in
like I kind of feel like a lot has been
made of this and I'm sure it didn't help
I'm not saying that
um you know that he would have come out
normal if he'd like grown up in a normal
household but I don't really know he
might have just been a sociopath from
the jump
but the household he grew up in was uh
his parents were what they call Plymouth
Brethren
which uh is a real
I don't know what I call them fanatical
they're pretty extreme uh very very uh
fundamentalist uh very very purist like
Bible
uh you know pretty much Bible stories
where all you were allowed to do it
wasn't it was one of those kind of like
no dancing no entertainment no anything
read the Bible this was the 40s well he
was well he was born in 1909 but he
started killing people in the 40s but um
yeah so they were like real real
religious strict
yeah
um and basically it was one of the
things where the Lord's always watching
you so you better not [ __ ] up and it's
like they believed in you know Mark of
the devil and all that other kind of
stuff so for non-western like I said not
probably didn't help for the non-western
audience or people are not really
familiar with the Christianity
especially old Christianity Christianity
is a damn genre of religious experience
based upon an entire genre of literature
it's a collection of Cults they all
believe different things God and
interpret these
books in different ways and it was weird
it even it there was no single unifying
Church
and uh England was had the Church of
England but it allowed a bunch of other
stuff
the United States was nothing but just
basically a collection of Christian
Cults and some large denominations but
the South was all Christian Cults most
of them Baptist Baptist Cults each
church was its own little thing I mean
when it's a church I'm talking about a
little building with a preacher and a
denomination
nothing it didn't connect anything else
it was like a little Private Business
had nothing to do with the state so each
one was better go
so you know no tell them what what they
would there's no telling what they
believed in they believed in different
versions of Christianity it was all
local
so
there's no overarching control in it so
that's what I'm trying to say nothing
Christianity said was that represents
Christianity everything's just an
individual take on it for the most part
very very strict yeah you know no
dancing no Sports no nothing you just
like sit around reading the Bible
um
later on like when uh John Hague was
older he said oh you know my childhood
was really lonely like I wasn't really
allowed to hang out with anybody like
his dad had built this really tall fence
like around the house so like nobody
could see in and they couldn't see out
it was just this whole like weird thing
I don't know how true it is because not
gonna lie like some of the stuff that he
said later on was probably [ __ ]
um so he might have maybe exaggerated
but the Plymouth Brethren cult were kind
of uh extreme gonna say that yeah uh
another thing too was that his dad
apparently used to tell him you know oh
the whole outside world is evil you know
so they can't like uh you know associate
with them probably no radio no TV no
yeah nothing like that I mean you know
obviously like in 1909 that was kind of
a little bit before that but yeah you
couldn't really you know you couldn't
like go to movies or you couldn't like
do I don't even think they were allowed
to like read other books or anything
yeah this wasn't that unusual my
granddad or my mother's side of the of
the family who worked for NASA McDonald
Douglas Grumman Aerospace he was an
aerospace engineer [ __ ] worked on a
[ __ ] bunch of projects like [ __ ]
the Saturn project worked on [ __ ]
um the nuclear [ __ ] propulsion rocket
that they were working on and everything
and he was like this he was
anti-television anti-radio it was just
prayer groups and Bible meetings and
homes they did
they were so strict that they that they
thought churches themselves were sinful
because the Bible says don't do that the
New Testament said don't do that you
could only meet in people's houses like
back in [ __ ] second century Rome all
right so this was actually quite common
in the United States too in this era
he's from my granddad was from this
generation
so not that unusual that's what I'm
saying the world has changed a lot
thankfully well yeah they were they were
a pain in the ass
yeah I mean they worried about stuff and
there's a few of them still around and
there's still a pain in the end yeah and
it didn't have anything to do with
intelligence my granddad was he was a
genius super intelligent but you could
fall
for these weird esoteric beliefs out of
these old [ __ ] books that it didn't
really have an impact on modern day
really
but you can get yourself jacked up and
to believe in things that
it's like LARPing they're LARPing if you
ask me live action role-playing Camp guy
said rock and roll is devil music I knew
it I knew a kid whose mother was against
rock music yeah I knew a couple kids
like that too yeah not so many in the
80s but it wasn't as uh
uh it wasn't it was a lot more
widespread than people might think you
know what I mean where like you weren't
allowed to like have any kind of like
rock music or anything John Smith said
it's almost like if you're exposed to
outside influences and ideas you might
question what you're being told yeah
exactly yeah that's why do you think
like cult 101 starting a cult is isolate
them from everyone else yeah and they're
only around other cult members that's
why they do that you would think a cult
like Bible Thumpers like that would not
be welcome in a military-industrial
complex especially the Aerospace stuff
which is all SC and he was working on
skunk work stuff and Lockheed Martin no
they sought them out because they
wouldn't talk
and they had and they usually came out
of religious universities so therefore
there was no way they would have any
communist sympathies that was the way it
was back then but they they had bible
thumper religious guys working in um the
military industrial complex especially
Aerospace because they could trust them
just different time
you can trust them to keep their mouths
shut
because they thought God was watching
them well they was they saw the United
States as a Christian country all right
they were they were in a cold war
fighting a Godless enemy called the
Soviet Union
so they they would keep their mouth shut
and they didn't they they didn't believe
newspaper they hated the newspapers
television and Hollywood they didn't
like any of those people so they
wouldn't talk to them you know they saw
them as communist sympathizers
so you didn't you didn't want to go to
Harvard University [ __ ] uh uh social
studies [ __ ] programs to get
scientists he wanted to go to [ __ ]
Christian private Christian colleges and
get guys that came were coming out of
the physics classes and uh Aerospace
back in those days you could become an
aerospace engineer a lot easier because
there was a lot less to learn you know
what I mean but it was it was mostly
just physics physics and things ideas
about mechanical stresses and you know
you know how hot could you get certain
types of Steel before they would bend
that kind of stuff grafter says granther
was raised in an Evangelical Church
looking back it was a mix of paranoia
victimhood and suspicion about rock
music movies literature Democrats media
and Democrats I think it kind of still
is yeah but
and I couldn't understand it it was
anti-heavy metal pissed me off
they didn't know what the [ __ ] they were
talking about stop messing with
you man I was more about I wasn't into
heavy metal but I was like quit taking
my horror movies away don't take my
parents work like that my parents didn't
give a [ __ ] about religion and that was
the old that was that was the old
Republicans that you you hear Democrats
complaining about a lot well that was
like my parents generation nowadays the
[ __ ] the Republicans of today listen
to [ __ ] Marilyn Manson and [ __ ]
heavy metal and [ __ ] they're not like
that anymore but yeah that pissed off
heavy metal was actually Christian if
you actually analyzed it because they
were always thinking about the what the
devil would do
well to believe in the devil you have to
be Christian they weren't as he that's
what I always thought yeah they were
just getting getting that back of the
parents and [ __ ] this to be honest
though I kind of feel like atheism even
when I was in college like in high
school and college
where you know where I grew up in
Daytona Beach
um I kind of feel like atheism was like
a step too far because if I was in a
class and like I didn't really think
that much about it yeah and you know and
I said something about like not
believing in God or something like that
and like everybody looked at me like I
had three heads and I was just kind of
like
yeah like to me it wasn't weird but it's
like all these other people are like
they like they're we're like like the
dude in Scanners yeah oh man they
[ __ ] the Bible Thumpers hated Iron
Maiden if you go [ __ ] read Iron
Maiden lyrics they never ready the
lyrics of the music well of course not
if you actually looked at why would they
like learn about something yeah the
whole ethos the whole ethos of [ __ ]
Iron Maiden was essentially Christian
really basically Christian I mean it
wasn't a religious band which is
probably why I wasn't really into it
it's all from the point of view of
[ __ ] the Anglican
point of view here I mean uh you know
because it was English and the British
Empire had its own church and the
sensibilities were judeo-christian
sensibilities and that's that's you know
Iron Man is filled with that you know
almost like [ __ ] ideas like chivalry and
right and wrong and
it's all there you know so it wasn't
satanic at all it just kind of had a
Sinister album covers well like I said I
kind of feel like a lot of people that
pissed and moaned about heavy metal or
horror movies or anything like that
didn't really get it they didn't really
watch them or they didn't really
understand like the whole context of the
[ __ ] I mean I'm not saying that
everybody has to like heavy metal or
horror movies or anything but don't
I I just like it pissed me off because
they didn't they obviously didn't know
[ __ ] about it if they didn't know [ __ ]
about it yeah you know what I mean and
they were talking about it like they
knew about it and I was like you that
song says number of the beasts they said
666. if you analyze the song the song is
about a dude who went out into the woods
and saw a satanic [ __ ] ritual and he
wasn't sure if he tripped it or if it
really happened that's all that's that's
what the song says yeah you know well
like I said they people like that which
is why I like I like that granthers used
the word victimhood yeah because people
like that like to think that they're
persecuted so it's kind of like part of
their whole thing so they're just kind
of like oh well everybody then also they
like to over dramatize everything
they're like big huge drama queens so
they're all the time it's just like oh
my God this is the worst thing ever it's
they're killing babies and all I'm just
like just please settle down no one's
doing that uh Zach said I remember
growing up in the 2000s and it was still
considered the edgiest thing ever to be
an atheist as a kid yeah it was actually
so pretty edgy I feel like into the
2000s because I was in college in the
90s like the early 90s and you know it's
in the South but
yeah people still looked at me like I
was [ __ ] insane like when I said that
even though to me it was just like
nothing so I was just like yeah why why
are you looking being an atheist was
more edgy edgy than being a Satanist
just ask Glenn Danzig that's what yes
well that's what I'm saying like if you
said you were a Satanist well because
when I was in junior high and looked
like a in high school and looked like a
goth like when they didn't know what
goth was back then so they would just
think you were a Satanist so they'd make
fun of you and beat you up and stuff but
they knew what that was like if you were
an atheist they were just like their
mouths would drop open they just had no
Concepts you're a freak yeah they had no
concept of that of that right they're
like throwing the Paradigm away that's
what I mean and to me it just seemed
very very strange I'm just like why is
that weird I don't I didn't understand
why it was weird yeah what was what was
weird for me is that now I'm getting
into my own personal thing we got time
because we didn't do we didn't do an
intro too much on this on this show
I always
I I always kind of believed that there
was a god
but I thought Christianity was just kind
of something that uh was stories left
over about some preacher [ __ ] From
Galilee and you know he was a wise man
and then uh but he was just a regular
mortal man and he was kind of
memorialized in the New Testament I
thought that was just a and I didn't
really think it was a bad thing but I
thought people were taking the [ __ ] too
far
uh yeah you're like oh man you know he's
saying good [ __ ] but he wasn't like you
he was a dude probably more like me he's
hanging out he's partying with these
women and [ __ ] telling you telling
everybody else that they're all uptight
you need to settle down
yeah he's doing hippie yeah
yeah kind of like a Marilyn Manson of
his day or something you know hey chill
the [ __ ] out you know well okay Marilyn
Manson of today is not the young Marilyn
Manson of our day back when he was going
on Jerry Springer having fun but anyway
that was a long time that's a long time
ago but um
over the time it just kind of evolved
into being a [ __ ] mythicist
um I'm not against religion I like
religions uh I don't think they're true
per se but
neither is King Arthur and those are all
great story great mythology there you
can learn just you know from mythology
kind of like what Joseph Campbell says
you know what I mean and mythology can
strengthen you well I mean there's
reasons that humans come up with those
stories over and over again right
but they can give you some insight into
how people think in their behavior yeah
that's all but as soon as I got into my
40s and really started to listen to guys
that know the bible really well all
right and can compare it to other Roman
religions and everything
if there was a guy named Jesus
none of him exists in the New Testament
anymore it was every every story about
him was something borrowed from a Roman
religion
so I'd say probably
there was no Jesus it's it's it's
Dionysus that they're talking about
well among other other gods it's totally
Roman and um it's that's just the way
Romans did religions
you know that's kind of like the MCU
basically that's what I mean it's like a
lot of people have like you know you
might think that's a glib comparison
it's totally not no not at all that's
basically the same thing basically the
same thing it's the same thing it was
the club scene behind it you got yeah
it's just that as far as I know nobody
knows nobody thinks like the Hulk or
Iron Man are real but but other than
that it's it's similar right it's the
same kind of thing well early Christians
are saying well was Jesus ever born in
the flashers are you just in the spirit
so they're saying things in the apolly
and Epistles so what it is is the early
Christians some of them believe that he
never lived other ones are thinking no
that was a real guy
you know but it there he was not a real
guy
it's an angel they're talking about
basically
Oracle said preacher's kid here I have a
very cynical view of institutional
religion because I've seen the backstage
stuff yeah I can imagine right well
that's usually why preachers kids turn
out to be like [ __ ] this [ __ ] like I'm
gonna go do all the drugs if you want to
embrace true spirituality and be able to
face death and the afterlife don't go
for institutionalized religion go look
at mythicism
and learn what mythology does
it'll you'll you'll understand
doesn't mean that it isn't true it's
just not the kind of true you're used to
it's a different kind of Truth
grandpa said funny how Christians reject
other religions for having bizarre
beliefs but they believe in the bizarre
like the version of which is well
Christian everything is bizarre if you
didn't grow up with it that's the thing
and I kind of feel like I think that was
one of the things that kind of got me
into like just rejecting religions
wholesale when I was a kid was that you
know you know whatever it is I said if I
had been born in the Middle East or if
I'd been born in China or something like
that I would have a completely different
set of beliefs than but you know people
don't really go outside I feel like a
lot of people didn't go outside of their
what they were raised with so everything
that they weren't raised with was weird
yeah and I was just like yeah but we're
weird to them like because they're used
to totally different stuff
Christianity is a perfect example of
darwinian evolution over time it evolved
into a belief system that could survive
for thousands of years and it did it
because it didn't commit to anything for
every one thing it tells you in one book
in another book and nowhere else in
another place it'll tell you exactly the
opposite so you can pick and choose like
for instance
if you were to ask the question can I as
a Christian eat meat that was sacrificed
to a Roman Idol
in one part it will say yes because
you're a Christian and you know that
that is not a real God that the Romans
sacrificed it to and you're a guest in
this person's house by all means eat
that meat it doesn't matter it doesn't
count it doesn't count because that is
just imagine that is not a real God and
there's no reason to offend your host
and then in another place in in another
book it'll say if you you ask the same
question should I eat meat sacrifice to
a Roman Idol that says hell no God will
strike you down you'll burn an Hellfire
so you can pick whatever one you want
and that allowed it to live a long time
survive for thousands of years
it's a darwinian Evolution through
literature
so
when you people think of Christianity
it's always their own version of
Christianity okay there's good stuff in
there and bad stuff depending on your
point of view and people are picking and
choosing what they depending on what
they're already like but yeah that's the
problem right you're just gonna you're
gonna bring to it whatever you're
already like whatever you're already
that's why I'm always like I always get
mad if people say that say oh we need
religion like for Morality I'm like no
you already have morality naturally
you're bringing that yeah to the
religion and having your own kind of
like thing but you already have those
beliefs and that doesn't mean that it's
that it's that it's that doesn't mean
that it's a that it's it's a
malfunctioning religion no it's
functioning that's what it was supposed
to do it's a mythology and that's what
all mythologies did they were to
strengthen you
okay and to strengthen your community
that's what they're for
um they survived the test of time you
know I mean uh that one has survived the
test of time is it literally true no no
but there's a lot of stuff that I
believed in in the army that wasn't
literally true but we won because we
believed it all right life is
psychological psychology is the main
part of the fight for survival
can you build new religions yeah kinda
but they all have to be rooted in the
past because the past is where the
authority comes from
and if there's if the past isn't there
you have to make a fake past to fit it
and they all did that Christianity did
that
it's a lot of stuff in the Christianity
like the crucifixion itself that's not a
historical event that didn't happen
it's it's an allegory for the for the
Jewish scapegoat ritual
you know that it's it's Jewish blood
magic you let the goat go and then
Slaughter the [ __ ] perfect lamb and
wash away the tribe's sins with it well
that's the same as letting Barabbas go
and Killing Jesus to save and through
his blood you're you're saving the sins
of people who have accepted his
sacrifice so you're except you're you're
they instead of sacrificing a lamb
you're sacrificing a demigod somebody
who is like Hercules his father was God
but [ __ ] the magical blood of that can
wipe away the sins of everyone
everywhere throughout time in the future
the past everything because even Moses
was saved by it he could go to prison go
go to prison he could go to heaven they
knew exactly what they were doing but
this is the MCU man this is literature
if this is mythology it's comic book
stuff but it
people read comic books to strengthen
themselves too same thing same thing
well that's what I mean that's why
that's why I don't [ __ ] on comic books
or movies or anything like that because
people are getting the same getting the
same thing out of it so you know don't
denigrate it it's the same thing right
it's the same thing just don't make
other Don't Force other people to
believe it that's that's part of the
thing that's your belief well yeah
that's where I have a problem like
believe whatever the [ __ ] you want but
uh you know the the moment that it
starts like infringing on other people's
[ __ ] then then we got a problem yeah no
no two cult agreed with one another
that's why the founding fathers said no
there is a God this and that but stop
all this religious [ __ ] because it'll
tear itself apart they
I don't want to they were secular in
some ways they were deists the founding
fathers were deists that'd be good well
they basically thought well uh God
created the world and then he sat back
and he doesn't and it's on all of
himself so they didn't believe that
prayer was effective or anything like
that no they didn't do stuff they
basically saw God the cree is like a
clock maker that just made it and then
somebody's like let it run they were
also Masons so a lot of times they
basically they're describing what they
would with the Masonic orders would call
the grand architect is what they're
taught and and it was non-denominational
you had Muslims in in the in the early
Masons uh I think we had one Muslim
convert was one of the founding fathers
I forgot which one it was but he was
also a Mason Masons could be of any
religion because they said yeah these
are our mythological Tales the true God
is a God we don't know yet we're going
to call him the [ __ ] grand architect
he made everything including these
religions well they didn't believe the
main thing was they didn't believe in an
interventionist like someone that could
intervent intervene and you like human
Affairs no it was like you're pretty
much on your own it was not the way of
the grand architect right you had like I
said he built it and then he was like
yeah you do it right right uh John Smith
says uh they're pointing out that
Aleister Crowley was also raised
Plymouth Brethren just like this
[ __ ] Okay yeah even though
Aleister Crowley I would argue turned
out like much better is as far as I know
Alistair Crowley didn't dissolve anyone
in acid no yeah so you know probably was
mostly just a [ __ ] fraud you know
well I mean he was just he was funny he
was just having a good team he was
having a good time shocking people even
though it was the inspired uh L Ron
Hubbard to create Scientology a certain
way yeah because uh
Crowley made a few bucks on the side
with uh by inventing some make a
[ __ ] or wizard programs if you
paid him enough he'd make you a wizard
that's right and you could level up John
Smith said true Crowley just ate poop
well I don't remember that
thing I advocate eating poop I'm just
saying if you're not hurting anybody
else I'm not gonna do it he must have
done that in some kind of ritual and I'm
not gonna like want to be around you if
you do it because that's [ __ ] gross
but
we have to do some really extreme [ __ ]
well let's eat poop I don't want to do
that yeah yeah but it'll be like super
shocking so really do we really have to
I can't think of anything else had he
been born in the early 70s he just would
have been a goth kid and 90s that's all
[Laughter]
no poop eating involved we've been
hanging out he'd have been hanging out
at the [ __ ] Vault or something down
in New York Camp guy said I heard
Crowley was a very rich kid with nothing
to do yeah I kind of feel yeah I kind of
feel like that happened a lot like super
rich and you could get away with a lot
more too like if you had money because
you know
obviously what I mean you know anybody
with money gets away with stuff all
right so uh so yeah we we got very very
distracted by this whole like religious
and then there's more of it because good
one of the things that his dad
said to him which may or may not have
made a big impression on it I'm not
trying to like excuse the dude I'm just
saying that
you know his childhood was probably like
kind of [ __ ] up and I do and I am
going to go out on a limb here I don't
know what the percentage is like right
off hand but it does seem like a lot of
serial killers were brought up in very
religious and or authoritarian
households I mean that really does seem
to be very common like not all of them
obviously because some of them just had
like really normal house with like
childhoods and were probably just like
[ __ ] up from birth but well anything
can happen because that's but I do feel
like a lot like maybe a disproportionate
amount of them did come from these types
of households
like that we're like super super strict
or super religious or super I mean
abusive obviously but well there's also
a lot of [ __ ] up kids that come out of
households that don't even have fathers
okay where the mother's not around and
there's no father and the kid just runs
wild then they go yeah that's good
that's not great either so yeah it's
just they tend to come from any kind of
extreme situation yeah maybe that's what
it is like any yeah because any kind of
extreme situation you're not gonna it's
gonna be much harder for you to like
integrate into so it's harder for you to
make friends it's harder for you to
relate to your parents like learn how to
like manage your emotions like that kind
of stuff so if that's not happening when
you're a kid then yeah it'll [ __ ] you up
later on so yeah so his dad
like I said thought the world was evil
and we need to keep ourselves apart from
that now his dad apparently had some
kind of like mole or some kind of or
something like on his forehead like some
kind of Mark and he told the kid oh this
Mark is there because I sinned in my
youth so it's like the mark of the devil
I've heard of that there were people
that believed that guy yeah so basically
like John Hague when he was a kid he got
like really freaked out by just like oh
my God if I do something bad I'm gonna
have like this but which like I said
it's not really that big a deal I don't
know what this Mark looked like like if
it was like some big [ __ ] up there may
have been molars I actually believed
that or he was just [ __ ] with a kid
but I think there were people that
actually believed that that if you
sinned your kids would come out kind of
[ __ ] up with marks on them yeah I've
heard that yeah but yeah so so he spent
a lot of his childhood so he said he was
like terrified that if he ever did
something bad then he would develop this
like Mark of the devil like on his
forehead now like the dad also told him
like well your mom doesn't have one
because she's like saintly you know what
I mean like so yeah now apparently like
I said according to I guess like
according to him and like maybe some
other people at Newman's time
but they said one of the kind of things
that maybe led him more toward getting
away from whatever this childhood
situation was was figuring out that his
dad was probably full of [ __ ] that whole
thing about you can't do anything bad or
like you're gonna grow a weird thing on
your forehead uh that he found out that
wasn't true because I think he did like
a couple bad like minor things like as a
kid like he lied about something or some
[ __ ] like that and then he kept like
expecting oh my God this [ __ ] [ __ ]
up thing is gonna like grow on my
forehead but it didn't so he's like that
[ __ ] lied to me you know what I
mean so I think after that he's like
well if you lied about that like what
the [ __ ] else is he lied about so he's
not that dumb I'm saying that so he did
like figure that much out when he was a
kid okay hold on one second
parachute Dooms going on about the
definitions of a cult
true definition of a cult is some is a
very small church that's all it is it's
not a negative comment connotation
people think that cult means something
bad it doesn't
it means it's real much smaller than a
denomination
you know Christianity started off as a
cult and then a bunch and then series of
competing cults
uh the only Christian the only the only
Christianity I would call True Religions
I guess you could say or would be
Eastern Orthodox the Catholic Church uh
Egyptian Coptic and
um
uh Church of England those are big
enough uh a church of Mormon is big
enough to be considered you know a
church or a denomination
um
but most of anything else anything
smaller than that be Cults Southern
Baptist is a cult
groups of cults
they're just local little church houses
with a [ __ ] Minister Pastor or not
past recall preacher that's a and
they're all self-styled
nothing wrong with it it's just that's
the way those churches are
they're called stuff
you know a little small tiny mini
religion that's all Zach says I'm
surprised no ex-scientologists have
turned out to be serial killers as far
as I know yeah you would think like as
[ __ ] up as that yeah [ __ ] is I mean
maybe I'd have to look that oh that
would be an interesting top I'm gonna
have to look that up like after
um John Smith sorry this was funny
Joseph said I'll bet the first thing
Abraham said to Isaac after the angel
intervened was best not to tell your
mother about this see that's what I
always thought when I read that Bible
story I'm like man that is [ __ ] up and
I think I was like seven or eight when I
read that I'm like that's [ __ ] up
that's yeah what they want me to [ __ ]
believe well they've changed the story
to try to erase a little bit of the past
or certain parts Judaism was kind of
like the ancient man getting back in the
cruise
ancient Judaism provided or or did he
did sacrifice child sacrifice the
firstborn always belonged or was always
sent back to God firstborn of any animal
and the firstborn
of any human was sacrificed they find
them in little clay pots every now and
then
uh so what they're doing is they've
written a story to
to commemorate
stopping that that that's no longer
required
I don't know if
Judaism was
not monotheistic it was kind of like
in the ancient times it was more kind of
like the Greek and the Roman Pantheon
they had Bunches of Gods
not one they had the father of the Gods
and all his sons one of them was Molek
and Molech was one that did fire a Human
Sacrifice by fire and then in the Yahweh
was one that wasn't God yet that was
sending children back to Yahweh
El Shaddai was the father of the Gods
but that all got re re-engineered into
monotheism later okay I mean Jenny's
going come on we got to go okay I know
it's like yeah I told you before I was
like really sleepy and I was like this
is not what the show's about you want
another drink yeah okay uh Allison
Wonderland said uh birthmark looking
like Baphomet that's kind of like what I
imagined when I was thinking about this
dude's dad I was like now what kind of
birthmark are we talking about does it
look like so that I imagine like
he's like this with like literal devil
horns like coming out of his head it's
like look son this is what will happen
if you do like some bad [ __ ] it's a
[ __ ] birthmark granther said
absolutely true that some serial killers
were raised in Evangelical Homes see I
thought like I said I don't know what
the percentage is but it does seem like
from all the serial killers and stuff
like that that I've read about a
significant portion of them uh do come
from Evangelical Homes because like I
said usually it's very like
authoritarian
um yeah he says the Bible is violent
xenophobic and misogynistic Tome yes it
is I agree Grant there's uh Buck the
trend and became a cop very fine line
between cops and criminals yo that
though yeah that is very true
yeah Gorbachev they're talking about his
uh birthmark so yeah so the whole uh uh
the whole birthmark thing
so apparently uh John Hague figures out
well I'm not gonna sprout a weird
birthmark on my head if I do something
bad which maybe in his kid brain led to
him thinking oh well if there's no
I don't know maybe he'd been raised with
kind of a an idea that if you do
something bad like it will physically
manifest on your body I'm just like
speculating here
but when that didn't happen and he
realized that his parents had lied to
him then he jumped from that to oh well
I can obviously just do anything the
[ __ ] that I want to because I do kind of
feel like he had that attitude now like
I'm saying it could just be that this
[ __ ] was a sociopath from the
get-go because he did seem to but I
don't know I don't know if it if he was
one of those guys that would have done
this [ __ ] up [ __ ] without being raised
like that or if it was a Confluence of
factors or what it was but at any rate
uh we know how it turned out
so 1934 uh he actually stopped he left
the Plymouth Brethren uh you know
religion and he married this woman who
was 21 and her name was Beatrice Hamer
now he didn't really know her all that
well I don't really know I don't even
remember like where he met her like you
know where he met her but it seemed like
he's like well maybe I should just get
married I kind of feel like just from
what I know about him maybe it was just
kind of like well you know guys like me
like should get married so you know
you'll do whatever so it was just like
that kind of thing
um now she was a little more reluctant I
guess like he was very Charming like a
lot of sociopaths are
um you know he had really good manners
he was like a just a normal looking dude
like I said you've seen pictures of him
he doesn't look like a monster he
doesn't look weird he doesn't look like
a creep or anything like that he just
looked like a normal [ __ ] dude and
for a while he sort of kind of had
normal jobs like he worked in like he
sold insurance and like he did
advertising [ __ ] like that like he just
had regular middle manager type jobs
so but she wasn't real sure about it but
she's just like whatever you know it's
the 30s um you know you kind of had to
get married so they did
now for a little while him and Beatrice
uh lived with John hague's parents
um you know the the weirdos
the weird religious people
now this marriage apparently only lasted
about four months
the marriage ended because John Hague
was arrested in October of 1934
and he got sent to prison for fraud
and this was the first of many many
times like I said he was one of those
[ __ ] like H.H Holmes that just
started like he's like well I don't
really want to have like a real job
where I have to like work or anything so
it's much easier to just defraud people
out of their money but he apparently
wasn't super good at it because he kept
getting caught
so he goes to prison for fraud now while
he was in jail Beatrice had their kid
who was baby daughter
now she you know because she's like well
this motherfucker's in jail and I I
guess she didn't want to raise the baby
by herself and like I said back in the
30s there would have been a horrible
stigma about it so she gave the kid up
for adoption
and uh then she's like okay well I'm
leaving this [ __ ] now John Hague
apparently saw her one more time and
said oh well we were never officially
married anyway because I already had a
wife which was not true but he told her
that so
keep it classy John uh so she took off
and after that uh John hague's very very
uh religiously conservative family uh
were like yeah [ __ ] you and they
basically I don't know if they disowned
him like formally but they were like
yeah we don't want anything else to do
with you
so John Haig moves to London in 1936 and
he starts working as a chauffeur
hey it's pookie
what's up pook Folk's gonna be on a show
you're gonna be on the show you want to
say something what do you want to say
you want to say something like [ __ ] all
this [ __ ] she's like I don't want to say
nothing yeah she stuck her tongue out
she was like his throat yeah she's like
why are you playing with her she likes
to throw she wants me to throw stuff at
her yeah so she can catch it
what yeah see what's the matter she sees
the screen
she's like oh my God you're right here
yeah you're right there
she saw herself maybe she did she's been
watching the screen you know [ __ ]
when I have the little tablet up people
talking because that's us
yeah okay well she seems to understand
like when she jumps up and looks at
herself in the mirror she seems to
understand that that's her yeah I take
my earbud out and put it in a hurry and
she's like what what and then for a
second she'll relax and I'll put it in
there and she'll look at them oh she
goes oh yeah that man's talking that
man's talking yeah it's funny she is
very funny yeah well and like I said
I've seen her look in the mirror too and
I'll be like that's Pooky and she's like
looking and then she'll look at me yeah
and then she looks in the mirror yeah it
takes a while to get super funny yeah
but yeah all right so this [ __ ]
starts working as a chauffeur
he works for this guy named William
mcswan now this dude was pretty wealthy
and he owned like a bunch of I don't
know if I'd call him like amusement
parks but they were kind of like um you
know this was the 30s so it was kind of
like this big like boardwalks where
there was like a lot of games and [ __ ]
like that like he owned a bunch of those
so uh so John Haig drove this guy around
and also like worked like maintaining
the machines like along the arcades or
whatever
now uh so they worked together for a
while and apparently like that went okay
and then he decided Well I need to do
some more fraud so because he was just
he was getting rusty I guess so he
decides to pretend that he's a solicitor
named William Cato Adamson
so he basically what he would do was he
would sell fake stock shares
um at below Market rates so he did this
for a little while so like I said we're
building up to some [ __ ] like H.H Holmes
used to do where they're always trying
to like Hey we're gonna do like fake
insurance policies or you know just like
selling stock and that kind of stuff so
he's doing that kind of stuff now
interestingly I was watching an earlier
video about this and they said this is
probably the only time in history that
like a grammar Nazi has has uh got
somebody caught for something somebody
noticed that the letterhead that he had
made
um had a misspelled word on it and for
whatever reason reported this to the
police because they were suspicious I
had no idea that like misspelling stuff
was illegal but I don't know I'm sure
there was more to it than that but yeah
he got reported to the police and the
police investigated and they're like
okay well this guy is uh completely fake
and he actually ended up getting a
four-year prison sentence for fraud
because of the [ __ ] he was doing selling
the fake he must have been an egregious
misspelling it wasn't it was actually it
was a city called Guildford which has a
D in it and he spelled it Guilford
without the D and that was apparently
enough to make somebody really
suspicious which like I said I guess if
you're a solicitor and you're selling
stock shares and you can't even spell
the name of your own city that is kind
of fishy right gonna say I mean I don't
know if I'd necessarily call the cops
about it but maybe they were like more
like maybe they were more into it I
don't know I don't know I'm just saying
uh so while he's in jail for this four
years like on this fraud sentence
he's like okay
um how what else can I do like to keep
from having to get a normal job
we have to do some more fraud but we
have to be more careful about getting
caught next time
so he's like I'm gonna start going after
Rich old ladies
and I'm going to basically not leave
Witnesses alive because that's kind of
gotten me into trouble yeah thus far
yeah so maybe if I kill them then
everything will be golden
now here's the funny part
he convinced himself that if there was
no body
then ipso facto there was no crime
somebody and he would not get in trouble
for it from what I understand it was
from
like I said this is about this
[ __ ] thinking he's like way
smarter than he is I think it was
because he misunderstood the concept of
Corpus delecti yeah Corpus delecti he
thought meant nobody no crime that's not
what that means
Corpus delecti only means it means the
body of the crime meaning that before
you can be prosecuted for a crime we
have to prove that a crime occurred it
doesn't have anything to do with there
being a dead body they can still prove
that somebody was murdered even if they
don't find a body if there's enough
other evidence and he apparently didn't
get that memo he seemed to legitimately
think that if there was no body then you
could like you could confess to the [ __ ]
and they still couldn't do anything this
is something he heard in the Zeitgeist
of the day too I mean sure they would
see things on crime movies and well
there's nobody there's no crime just
because some character in the movie said
that because some dude who wrote that
and he was like oh that's true there's a
lot of that [ __ ] going on but being I
mean light bulb goes on and it goes to
the highest levels of [ __ ] society
I've heard [ __ ] people in charge a
whole government say [ __ ] about Warfare
totally not true where their whole
understanding of warfare came from
movies
you know I mean they don't really think
about that you know [ __ ] feet you
know there's certain things you can only
know if you serve in in militaries
during wartime so it's the same thing
not in
it's not just dumb asses okay so-called
intelligent people fall victim to that
[ __ ] syndrome
because they heard it in other places
they think they know something about it
they don't
but that's kind of the whole thing I
mean I will submit uh that it is more
difficult to
prove murder for example if they don't
have a body but if there is a
preponderance of other evidence
if it's enough then yeah they can
absolutely convey and it has happened
before like I said it's harder but it
can be done but he seemed to really
think and we'll get into like some [ __ ]
later that says that he absolutely did
believe this that if there wasn't a body
then there's no there wasn't anything
that anyone could do about it you could
even run down the street and say I
killed so and so and everybody's like
well we can't do anything there's nobody
you know what I mean totally untrue that
is not true that is not true just in
case you were like there are people that
went to death row with no bodies yeah
like I said it's harder to prove it but
you know obviously much easier if you
have a body but if there's enough other
evidence then there's a missing person
and then somebody comes forward says I
saw that person kill that other person
then they can do the place in time where
they where where the crime scene was and
uh you get you get that person in front
of a [ __ ] jury no you'll you know
what I mean the testimony sounds good
you can [ __ ] get you can get the dude
convicted well and the thing about this
dude if you didn't do it you can get him
convicted the thing about that this
dumbass too was that
I think he had the mistaken idea that
yeah I could just dissolve these bodies
and but it didn't dissolve him
completely it's like there's still
evidence Left Behind yeah stupid yeah
you know what I mean so it's like I mean
you know you could indict it and you can
indict a ham sandwich that is true and
you can convict anybody in front of you
get them in front of a right jury
you could even convict the innocent so I
don't know what this [ __ ] is
thinking about
like I said this dude was uh not that
bright right not that bright if they
think you're if they think you killed
somebody you're responsible for somebody
who's come up missing they're gonna get
a conviction on you
just the way it's gonna happen
I mean and like I said a lot of it has
to do with you know what jury you get
what judge you get what you know how
much money you have that too if you
can't afford a [ __ ] really that's
probably like a that's a factor sadly
but yeah if you're broke you're [ __ ]
you're at their Mercy
yeah so I'm in big trouble yeah but
I just have to like never go outside if
you're well connected and got millions
of dollars you're gonna walk
mostly yeah I mean 99 of the time yeah
or they'll get like a much lesser
sentence and even if they do get
convicted they'll spend it in like some
cushy [ __ ] yep Country Club of a
prison somewhere you better fight your
way out of it you got dirt on other
people you'll never even get you'll
never get convicted
so okay so because this [ __ ]
thought that like while he was in prison
he decided
um well I need to figure out how to like
get rid of the bodies then
so he starts working with sulfuric acid
now uh there was some sulfuric acid in
the prison I guess it was like in the
tin shop
so what he would do is he would catch
mice in the prison and then dissolve the
poor mouses and then he would dissolve
them in the acid to see how long it
would take and then he would extrapolate
you know if the mouse is X size then how
long would a human take like a mouse in
case you wanted to know takes about 30
minutes to dissolve in sulfuric acid so
he's like okay well how long would a 200
pound human being take [ __ ] like that so
he's doing like some mathematical [ __ ]
like I said probably thinking he was
like super super intelligent when he did
like the mathematics to go to go with
that so uh so yeah I will say too that I
think that he got the idea for the
sulfuric acid
from this dude uh this French murderer
named George Alexandra Saray and he had
also disposed of bodies using sulfuric
acid now Saray was actually guillotined
for a double murder that took place in
1925. he might have been the last person
guillotined in that uh particular area
of France I can't really remember but he
only I mean only killed two people but
kind of for the same reasons that uh
that George Hague did but that's where
George hey got the idea from that she's
like oh that french guy he had a good
idea he just liked his own but he but
the stupid thing is that obviously that
guy still got caught and beheaded though
I mean did that last part of the story
like not resonate or
I was just kind of like I thought
because I thought his whole thing about
like having to dissolve the bodies and
acid was so he doesn't get caught
because there's no body I'm like yeah
but that guy dissolved people in acid
and he got caught and he's executed
these mothers they think they're
Geniuses okay that's what I mean and
really to man I don't want to help but
I've said so much [ __ ] good [ __ ] on
this show over the years
and I'm saying well I don't want to help
any of these [ __ ] but it is
they're not watching this [ __ ] well they
might be I don't know it is so [ __ ]
easy okay
um you just have to have practical
skills and all you got to do is just
look at the skills that Hunters use for
field dressing and the skills that
regular food industry guys with [ __ ]
butchering okay
it is so sanitary so easy to field dress
a deer in the field
and to separate things like internal
organs from the skeleton and the meat
and the hides and everything and you can
do this in a clean pristine environment
in under an hour
okay
these dudes are so [ __ ] bone
head-headed you know and you won't even
lead very many traces behind like blood
or anything and it's not even Macabre
it's part of food processing a basic
skill that Stone Age level Hunters had
you don't even need Advanced [ __ ]
equipment groups of men with pieces of
handheld pieces of volcanic glass or
sharpened [ __ ]
sharp and [ __ ] what's a flint sharp
and Flint cutting tools
a group of three or four guys could
reduce a [ __ ] elephant down into
[ __ ] small packageable cookable parts
within a few hours
and with no waste okay something the
size of a deer or a human
[ __ ] Child's Play
were you worried about all this [ __ ]
about how I gotta get acid I gotta do
this this and that what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
and I kind of feel like if you're buying
sulfuric acid maybe not so much right
there but everybody's like why are you
buying sulfuricat um yeah I don't know I
just I like collecting sulfuric acid
disposal can be Mafia style if you have
good connections put you in a trunk have
the [ __ ] car [ __ ] crushed and
[ __ ] melted that's the Detroit way
okay down the scrap yard uh if it's some
[ __ ] homemade same way you would
process a deer for food same thing
same [ __ ] same thing
but what it is they're cowards they're
squeamish they don't have any [ __ ]
nope I don't even think it's that I just
think they're not that bright they're
not that stupid yeah yeah you don't even
get dirty you don't even get dirty I
just think they're not that bright yeah
they're overthinking it yeah overthink
it
they're overthinking it yeah okay we're
not trying to help anybody no I'm just
saying no they're the answers well how
do you do that in a house bathtub
if you were gonna clean a deer you take
the [ __ ] to the bathtub if you're
gonna have to do it indoors usually we
didn't though we usually would
put a chain around the neck and use a
[ __ ] carry-all and [ __ ] Jack them
up in a [ __ ] lower tree limbs so
they're hanging up and then that's
that's we would process them outside and
underneath the deer you have [ __ ] um
ice chest with no ice in it but you're
putting all the meat in there and then
you transfer it all to a freezer
well you can transfer it somewhere else
if you wanted to
just dumb dumb going through all this
[ __ ]
Danny Rowling is telling some really
really funny acid jokes yeah what do you
call someone who only drinks kosher
hydrochloric acid an acidic Jew
that's pretty good actually because that
qualify as a Jewish joke that's racist
I mean not really
it's just it's a pun yeah I know it's
not really a Jewish joke it's just that
one it was a joke yeah
I mean there yeah there are some good
ones Danny Rowling said there was a
maniac in town earlier today threatening
to Splash passersby with acid thankfully
police managed to neutralize him
I'm liking all the acid jokes I really
do
um all right
so yeah
Acid Bath
so John Hague gets out of prison and he
thinks oh boy I'm about to put my like
Acid Bath dreams
in into like production
so now while he was uh I guess waiting
to go back out on his own he's staying
with his family how does this
[ __ ] like always find somebody
to stay with I don't know but he's
staying with his family called the
Steven family
and then he uh befriends one of their
daughters Barbara
who was actually 20 years younger than
him
but was kind of became his girlfriend
this dude is like a [ __ ] fraudster
and a potential serial killer and yet he
still gets a girlfriend so you know
but like I said he probably he came
across like what everybody said because
he's a sociopath and a lot of sociopaths
come across as like very very Charming
so a lot of times they can uh they can
really like uh charm people if you're
not really like paying Too Close of
attention now Ash if you know them for a
while then you're like oh this
motherfucker's like evil you know what I
mean but maybe he was like he seemed
like a really Charming person that's
what most people said and he was able to
talk people into some [ __ ] that nowadays
I don't think you'd be able to talk
people into you know what I'm saying so
I think that was that
[Laughter]
he's here in New York at New York minute
in New York hour
sure yeah well people come they drop by
when they can drop by everybody have his
lives as you know they can't just like
drop in and watch us stupid yapping like
you've been up to maniac
we're on like almost every goddamn day
people probably get sick of looking at
our reaction faces
before
it was in a car accident and then he got
a head wound
um which you know good considering what
happened to him later
now he said later that this was the
event that kind of like
he had grown up and I don't know how
much of this is [ __ ] because like I
said some of the stuff that he said
after he got arrested I'm sure is
completely [ __ ]
but he said when he grew up because of
the religious uh you know household that
he grew up in that he had like a bunch
of like [ __ ] up nightmares
but they'd gone away he said that in
1944 after he got the head injury in
this car accident that he had like all
the the [ __ ] up nightmares like
started again now this is an actual
quote from him this is what he said that
he dreamed about like I said I don't
know if he made this up or not but he
said this was what the dream was I saw
before me of four oh thank you Ian
England happy Wednesday thank you very
much thank you very much thank you thank
you thank goodness if you all want to
[ __ ] give Jay some flash bulbs go
ahead and send him now I'll [ __ ] sit
here and record them all
I'll enter them into the system
[Laughter]
misery review today and I and I forgot
to mention how much I liked like the cop
and his wife and that he's like I'll
enter into the system and he writes it
on a post it sticks it on the wall and I
was like that's like my system
[Laughter]
except I usually like type it into some
[ __ ] thing and like yeah forget
where I put it yeah but yeah uh so yeah
so this was the dream that he had he
said I saw before me a forest of
crucifixes okay which gradually turned
into trees at first there appeared to be
due or rain dripping from the branches
but as I approached I realized it was
blood oh
hardcore the whole Forest begins to
begin to rise and the trees darken erect
Darkness
[Laughter]
yeah uh yeah that sounds like a white
girl's looking for new experiences
that's yeah that definitely sounds like
a porn type yeah yeah dark interact yeah
uh to ooze blood a man went from each
tree catching the blood when the cup was
full he approached me drink he said but
I was unable to move
I suspect and like I said we'll get into
why later I don't know if he made this
up because later on spoiler alert like
after he got caught
I think he was trying to go for an
insanity defense and it's like yeah I
didn't just like kill those people for
their money and dissolvement asset also
I drank their blood because I'm crazy
you know what I mean so I kind of feel
like he was making [ __ ] up
so I don't know if he actually did he
may very well have had that dream
there's no way to prove it
so after the car accident though like I
guess he recovered and then he rents
like this basement apartment
um and he set up his Workshop which is
where he's gonna start his new career in
frauding people and feeling very much
thank you camp guy tell me about the
t-shirts just when you hit the right
spot in the podcast
yeah
what t-shirts yeah which ones I think
he's wait you want us he wants to know
what t-shirts we have I think
um all of them we're talking about them
yeah okay so yeah so he sets up this
Workshop
this is where I'm gonna uh kill people
and dissolve them in acid you know
that's his dream and he's living it
so
happening at this point very much by
chance
he's at a pub in Kensington
and John Hague uh sees his old employer
mcswan
the guy that he used to be a chauffeur
for the guy that owned like all the
amusement parks and stuff
so he's like hey Mac what's up because
that's what he called him
so they uh so they start hanging out
again and I guess that John Hague had
like known Max parents from back in the
day and like the parents were like
thought he was great
like I said sociopath
so he's like hey my mom and dad have
been asking about you my mom and dad's
name were uh Donald and Amy by the way
so he's like yeah Donald and Amy been
asking about you why don't you come see
him
so they all have this big like [ __ ]
reunion man
and then during this reunion Donald and
Amy happened to mention oh man we just
like invested in all this property at
which point John Hay goes chi-ching like
silently
I imagine
so uh so basically what John Hague did
he starts hanging out with his former
friend but still his friend as far at
least as far as Mac knows so they're
hanging out together being like hey bro
what's up like and he just starts like
hanging out with the um the parents and
everything all the while planning to
kill them so you know hanging out for
several weeks you never know man never
know
so he on September 9th 1944
he's like um okay well today's the day
I'm gonna do the [ __ ]
so what he did was he got
um one of them to come there like mcswan
to come there
and he's like hey why don't you come to
my like basement thing I'm gonna show
you some [ __ ] or talk to you about some
Investments or some crap like that he'd
always like say some stuff like that to
get people to come to his little place
so once they were in there he would
usually he would either shoot them
although the earlier ones he usually
would hit them with a pipe so he would
just like come up behind you was like
hey bro what's up I'm gonna go get you a
drink or something like that Wham and
then he would like hit him with a pipe
and then he would slip throat
now he says about mcswan he said oh
after I slit his throat then I had like
a mug right there and I like had the
blood pour out and then I drank it like
I said I kind of think that was [ __ ]
but he said that later because he was
trying to get an insanity defense maybe
he did it I don't know but it seems like
Overkill because like I said it seemed
like most of the motive that he had for
killing people was purely a financial
motive so I don't really think he got
any kind of like sexual
thing out of it I think he was just
eliminating people whose money he wanted
so he kills mcswan and then he has uh
this 40 gallon barrel I think it was 40
imperial gallons so it might have been
48 actual gallons so then he puts
mcswan's body in there and then fills it
up with sulfuric acid that's a lot of
sulfuric acid now that I'm thinking
about it 40 gallons of where the [ __ ] do
you get that like I said I'm sure it was
easier to get back then but
I mean the fact that nobody like was
like hey bro why are you buying like 40
gallons of sulfuric acid I mean that's
got to say something
so
now the first
time really thought this through I feel
like
because he puts the body in the barrel
and then he pours all the sulfuric acid
in there okay fine
but
um when the body's in there and the acid
is in there like it starts smoking like
the fumes come out right and he didn't
have a mask or gloves or anything the
dude was not
I don't know what he thought was gonna
happen I'm like dude it's acid if you're
using acid to dissolve a body then
probably you don't want to touch it or
smell it or anything like that I mean
you would think that would be pretty
Elemental but he apparently didn't that
didn't occur to him I guess so so yeah
so he pours it all in there he's like it
starts steaming and it's like it gives
off all this heat which he wasn't
expecting and he didn't have a mask on
or anything so like holy [ __ ] so he had
to like run outside
so you had to run outside like I said it
would be funny if it wasn't like a
person being dissolved in acid so you
know
so he's like okay so after a while he
goes back in there and then covers the
drum back up
and he's like okay I'm gonna leave that
[ __ ] in there and like dissolve
for a little while this is so messed up
so he just left a bit there like all
night like like leaving a roast in a
slow cooker I don't know it's just like
[ __ ] up
now uh he said that during that night
after this first murder that he had like
a whole bunch more like nightmares and
stuff like that but you know boohoo
whatever
now the next day he comes back and
checks on his handiwork
and what's left of mix one
they said basically he's like basically
it was just a bunch of cold liquid and
some lumps
so all that was left in the barrel he
just poured it down uh a drain
and apparently he felt like super
Jasmine's like oh my God I just killed
somebody and dissolved them and asked
that's awesome like he kind of like had
this really weird
he like he got like really like kind of
Pumped about it which like I said that's
that's kind of [ __ ] up
so yeah I I don't know I just find it
very very funny like it's not funny
because the dude got killed and like
dissolved an acid but I just thought it
was like really funny that like he
didn't
prepare for what the acid would do like
he didn't have a mask or anything I just
thought that was like kind of funny
so yeah so he dumps the guy I think that
I think this when I first read about
this guy I think this is what really got
me that like he dissolves the guy into
like some lumpy sludge and then pours
him down a drain and I'm just like man
that is [ __ ] up like that you can do
that to a person just like poop down the
drain you go yeah there it was okay I
can handle Camp guy if you want to do it
he's got a caracal he wants to get a
couple more shirts oh okay you want to
go okay what I'll show him what I got
all right
just a quick commercial
these are the shirts that I have right
now
and they can be on any kind of shirt
uh 20 Super Chat for uh small to large
anything above large got to be 30
because uh the shirts cost more
I got
a Tyrell industry
um replica shirt
okay
got one of those
any size you want
got a large snake pliskin
image
I got ocp Communications
the only choice
I got Omega Man
see if I can get that image there it
goes
Omega Man
they can be on muscle shirts or any
other shirts
Carl Co Studios
although I think he said he has one of
those and then I got this one this is my
favorite
Canon Studios you will never get these
studios are out of business
but they're all handmade damn they're
all handmade thank you camp guy I want
Tyrell and carolco extra large crew neck
already have the Bliss okay
I know Tyrell and Carol Co okay extra
large all right we got you man thank you
for the generous generous one
and I'll make you some special ones I'll
even put the 13 o'clock logo on the back
all right we wrote that down thank you
very much I'm gonna send you a gift with
that too all right yeah we can find all
kinds
all right yeah Samantha said who would
pour that down the drain crazy people
crazy people
but yeah
so
so he dissolved his friend and poured
his friend on the drain
and then he goes to his friends parents
Donald and Amy
and says oh
um your son was gonna get drafted into
the war and ran away so he was to avoid
conscription
um and he even went so far as to like
send fake postcards from him like so
like you know maintain the illusion that
he was still alive
uh so basically he's like well I have to
maintain the illusion he's still alive
because he was trying to get all his
money right I mean that was the reason
that he killed him and [ __ ]
so he was kind of like working on that
now
while like the next murder he committed
though he did actually he's like okay
well now I actually need like some
equipment for this stuff I can't just
like pour acid in there and like hope
for the best so he made like some pumps
and like a face mask and [ __ ] like that
like you know you would think that he
would have better planning but no he had
to like [ __ ] up first and then do it
now uh he also killed they don't know he
wasn't convicted of this but he did like
say later on that while he was he had
killed mcswan and then he's like okay
I'm gonna kill the parents too because
they had a [ __ ] ton of money and he knew
them
but before he did that he said that he
killed this other woman in Hammersmith
now they don't know who this woman is
they don't know if he just made that up
or you know if this was a woman that
nobody missed or anything like that or
he was just doing his practice that's
why I say that you know they know that
he killed six people for sure but
they're think that he might have killed
more because he said oh I killed this
person and that person but he didn't
sometimes know who their names were
so uh mcswan's parents Donald and Amy
they disappeared on July 2nd 1945.
now he lured them to his little basement
uh apartment Workshop thing
and then hit them over the head with
lead pipe lead pipes
and then he killed both of them and said
he drank their blood I don't buy it but
okay
and then dissolve them in the acid
barrels
after that he goes to the mcswan's
landlady and says oh they went to the
U.S
um and they before they left they said
that you should forward all their mail
to me because that's how that happens
that's not suspicious at all
and that included uh Donald mcswan's
pension checks
so everyone was like okay sounds legit
which okay
this is an 1940s but come on
that's it's super fishy
but so he starts getting all the mail
and then he starts forging the sun's
signature on like The Power of Attorney
form so he can like take over their [ __ ]
he also forged a deed on a property that
was owned by the mom Amy mcswan and kind
of took it over like in a false name so
from this whole
fraud like this whole debacle that he
pulled
he managed to make two thousand pounds
in back in those days money now today in
American money that's about thirty nine
thousand six hundred dollars so
not bad for dissolving someone an acid
but you know like because he sold the
property later on
he sold a bunch of their other [ __ ] too
that he got control of because he had
all their mail forwarded and made about
six thousand pounds or in today's
American money about a hundred and
nineteen thousand dollars from that
whole situation
now he would also even while he was
killing people he was still like having
all these little side gigs too like all
this kind of stuff where Hey I'm
um I'm a patent officer and I you know
he'll he'd set up like little fake
businesses all the time
um and he said also that around this
time too that he killed a guy named Max
that was all that he said he said his
name was Max from Kensington and
apparently like took his money but they
never figured out who that was
now the thing about John Hague though
and I kind of feel like this is true of
a lot of these types of [ __ ]
is that the reason they get into fraud
is because they want a [ __ ] ton of money
without working for it
and the reason they want a [ __ ] ton of
money is because they have really
expensive taste they want to like
basically like you know blow it on
cocaine and hookers and that's and well
gambling I think in John Hayes such a
big situation was kind of like the big
thing so he was like a big Gambler so he
would get these massive sums of money
from the people that he dissolved and
then he would spend it like he would
just go race he's like woohoo payday and
then he would just go and like [ __ ]
Gamble and like just stay in like real
expensive hotels like all that kind of
stuff so it wouldn't last very long and
then he's just kind of like oh [ __ ] now
I have to like dissolve somebody else
and acid you know what I mean so it's
it's kind of like a a whole like [ __ ]
situation that comes about cap guy you
were very generous today I'm
[ __ ] I'm gonna hook you up I'll
woke you up I got some [ __ ] I'm gonna
send you yeah yeah I know that was that
was really really awesome really very
nice
um all right so by the time that most of
the mcswan's money was gone
I mean do you know how long it would
take me to like spend how much did you
get like 150 Grand holy [ __ ] it would
take me like forever to go through that
kind of money but yeah but he went
through it like almost immediately so
he's like okay well we gotta find some
more
marks
so he picks out another couple Dr
Archibald Henderson who at the time was
52 and his wife Rose uh who was 41. now
at the time that he targeted them they
were apparently like selling their house
so they were kind of like on the market
so he kind of approached them either as
a real estate agent or like he was
trying to buy their house like that's
kind of how he got into their good
graces and also then he was just kind of
like he found out some [ __ ] about them
so that he could kind of approach it
it's like oh I'm gonna do the same [ __ ]
as you so you know what I mean he was
that kind of he was that kind of
[ __ ] and so while he cultivated
a friendship with them he was able to
get like a lot of information about
their the stuff that they owned so he
could like get it later on
so then he rents this other place
another Storehouse
um in Crawley and so he moves all his
stuff from the old workshop with the
drain to another place that spoiler
alert did not have a drain
so
uh so yeah
and he said he moves into this new place
and immediately like orders a whole
bunch of like 40 gallon drums and a
whole [ __ ] ton of sulfuric acid nobody
said boo hmm
how do you do that who knows but he did
he's like hey I need a bunch of barrels
and Sofia I guess what am I doing
nothing nothing yeah nothing suspicious
at all
so I mean it's used in metal working but
it is not Machining anything that's what
I mean come on I kind of feel like it's
one of those things well that's kind of
like why after a certain time period
like after [ __ ] like for
example like start getting poisoned now
when you go and buy a specific kind of
like poison or chemical everybody's like
what do you want this for you know what
I mean like you have to sign off on it
so if somebody turns up dead later on
like we're not liable you know so I kind
of feel like maybe I don't know maybe
some oversight there I know there are
legitimate uses for sulfuric acid and
stuff but come on barrels and all that
kind of stuff
so February 12th 1946 uh he drives the
the man Dr Henderson to his little
workshop there and shot him in the head
and he used the dude's own gun which you
know that's that's not cool
and then like so he leaves the body in
there and he's like now I'm gonna go get
the wife
so he goes to get the wife
he drives her the store she didn't
really want to go it seemed like but
then she was just kind of like okay
so they go in there what he would
usually do is be like hey kind of look
at that thing over there and then he
would like shoot him in the back of the
head so at least they apparently didn't
know what was happening but I mean that
doesn't make any better I'm just saying
so he shot her from behind and then tied
up like kind of like trust up the bodies
like her and her husband and then just
left them there overnight now later he
told police that he drank blood from him
too but again I don't think I buy that
now this time so he puts the bodies in
the barrels with the sulfuric acid like
he did before
however this time it didn't really work
out as completely as it had the last
time because Dr Henderson's foot for
whatever reason was not dissolved I
don't know if it was just because the
foot was left sticking out or if he had
like metal at his foot I don't really
know or it was like shitty acid I don't
really know but anyway there was like a
foot left
so doc but you know it's like John Higg
was just kind of like well you know
mistake's gonna happen you're just gonna
have to like deal with it
so he basically he was like I said he
was so arrogant like he literally
thought
that a foot was not gonna
raise any suspicions
and like I said this new place that he
rented didn't have a dream in the floor
so he dissolves both bodies except for
that foot which was that persistent foot
which was still there so that persistent
foot want some more ice sure okay
so he says well I don't have a drain so
I'm just gonna go out back in the garden
where there was kind of like a little
garbage pile thing and I'm just gonna
dump the barrels in the corner of the
garden including the foot including the
foot
this dude like I said he's not smart
he's not smart
uh and I think that he got to a point
where he was just like so because he'd
gotten away with it a couple of times
and nobody questioned him there were no
cops coming around nothing like that so
he's just like well [ __ ] man I can do
anything I'm just gonna dump this
[ __ ] foot like right in my [ __ ]
yard and No One's Gonna Do Anything
I kind of feel like that was where he
was coming from
so yeah
now at this point like I said because
he's trying to get all their money after
he dissolves them in acid he has to sort
of like keep maintaining the illusion
that they're still alive so he has to
like Forge letters in their names and
you know Forge letters like back and
forth to other people it's like it's
point like I said if you're doing all
this stuff you might as well just get a
job I mean this seems like a full-time
Endeavor
um and
all of the work that it entails and all
of the worry that it entails like I said
you might as well just get a [ __ ]
regular job okay because at this point
you're just like [ __ ] doing all this
kind of stuff
so he ends up uh from this particular
escapade
he got like selling their properties and
selling their stuff and everything like
that he got about 8 000 pounds in that
in like 1940s money which is about 158
000 in American money today
um also this is kind of [ __ ] up uh
remember the girlfriend Barbara that he
had he gave Barbara some of the ladies
clothes hey I found these clothes they
might fit you yeah I totally didn't
dissolve this lady in acid what are you
talking about yeah I mean can you
imagine how [ __ ] cold-blooded you
would have to be he's trying to get laid
off his murders that's what I mean
I mean for some reason it's like it's
bad enough like all the [ __ ] that he did
but like little [ __ ] like that I don't
know why that just like kind of sticks
in my crawl like that kind of stuff
yeah Hugo if you ever need any shirts or
something just hit us up oh [ __ ] we
can work it out and look I'm just doing
the shirts because that's an easy
product if you're a regular customer if
you want to do want me to make images on
something else like say I don't know a
[ __ ] backpack or something for your
car or something
we can talk about it offline or online
I can put those images on anything as
long as I have it and I will note too
that I accidentally bought some screen
printing ink that can be used on other
things other than that can be used on
things other than fabric like paper and
wood like paper and wood and stuff so if
you want some other stuff printed it's
like I got to use it somehow right
because I bought I I I mistakenly bought
like not the stuff or fabric like they
got the other stuff so I have like a
whole big huge [ __ ] thirty dollar box
yeah and if somebody wants custom images
just drop a suggestion suggestion
and uh in the comment section whatever
we'll talk about it I can put them on
anything I still got to do a silver
Shamrock we got to do a silver Shamrock
maybe I'll try to get to it this weekend
but I'm like I've been like super super
busy I wanted to do
um uh some more Wayland yutani stuff I
actually was thinking about something
Predator one like what would Dutch's
security companies what was his what
would his company logo look like because
they were mercenaries they were an army
but he had to have some kind of a
security company to do that mission what
would it look like you know just [ __ ]
like that I was thinking of something
with Predator one
something that's alternate universe
you know something that's not violating
copyright
well that would be an original design I
kind of feel like there's a lot of that
stuff going on because I saw somebody on
a podcast the other day that was wearing
like a um
what was it like a quince boat rentals
right sure like it was yeah it was like
kind of cool and it looked like all
distressed and everything yeah what
would his [ __ ] look like just anything
you know yeah so there's like a whole
sub genre yeah it's like if you guys
have any ideas and you want me to make
it we'll talk about it
Danny Rowling said it was probably
amusing to him to write to the victim's
family and friends Etc I kind of feel
like it was I kind of feel like he got
off on it because he thought he was
getting away with something like he's
like man I'm killing people and like
nobody suspects anything so he's just
like writing all these letters like yeah
they're doing great they're on vacation
and blah blah yeah it's like that kind
of [ __ ]
now uh at this point
like somebody like one of the family
members starts to get a little bit
suspicious
but John Hague is able to come out and
go oh you know what happened Dr
Henderson actually like performed an
illegal abortion on somebody and so he
was gonna get in trouble so both of them
like took off to South Africa like to
avoid prosecution and apparently the
family member was like okay sounds legit
yeah yeah well like I said you know from
by all accounts he was actually like a
smooth talker and he did actually like
convince people of stuff and he seemed
like a normal person like he didn't seem
crazy or sociopathic or anything like
that even though he clearly [ __ ] was
um so yeah but I mean he would even plan
I found this on one like article it said
that basically uh a friend of his that
he had gone to school with like a long
time ago
um he noticed in the obituaries that
their mom had died and he was just kind
of like maybe I can like go there and
like exploit that situation you know
what I mean he just seemed like he just
wanted money and he didn't really care
about people at all so that's what I
mean when I say that he was like a
goal-oriented killer you know what I
mean
um so he was absolutely gonna do that
but then like you know that person died
too and he didn't really get to it so
again like all the money that he made
like 158 000 almost 159 000 that he got
from like the last murders that didn't
last long either because like I said
he's blowing through the [ __ ] I don't
know what the [ __ ] he's doing
gambling expensive hotels blah blah
um but it's running out again so he's
like okay well I need to like cultivate
another victim at this point
so he meets uh his last victim at the
same Swanky hotel where he was staying
at
this was Olive Durand Deacon who was 69
years old
now she was wealthy because her husband
who had died
uh was a solicitor named John Durand
deacon
so like I said she lived in the same
hotel as it's called the Onslow Court
hotel so that's where they both lived
and it's kind of like a fancy place but
she was living in there he was living
there and he was like Hey the old lady
what's up like I heard you have money
something like that
um and at this point he's telling people
he's an engineer
and I guess him and Olive got to talking
and she actually had a business idea
for I think like fake fingernails which
I guess I'm like wow she was like ahead
of her time because they were like
making yeah so I don't know if anybody
had those like in the 40s I don't think
so
but that was good over time yeah yeah
that was like a business idea she had
I'm like wow that was like pretty
brilliant because now like everybody has
that [ __ ]
so
but of course she never got to do it
because she got [ __ ] put that [ __ ] on
there and do a porn scene and then they
vanished
what does porn have to do with it has a
lot of fake fingernails well I know but
a lot of people wear fake fingernails
not just porn stars maybe that's just
that's just where your brain yeah that's
where you mostly see it I mean you in
club night I try to get yeah I try to
tear them fake fingernails up though you
never like nah I had too much to drink
see that's how the [ __ ] goes well I mean
I don't I have like shorter ones and I
like those those are good for it because
honestly if you wear those big long ones
it's not practical it's really not
practical like especially if you're
going out to the club and it's like you
know if you actually didn't even put the
seat belt on yeah it's it's just kind of
like that and then like if you have to
go to the bathroom it's like I can't get
my clothes off it's like they're
snapping off and I'm just like that's
why I was saying that's why I said porn
they're just sexual they're just sexual
that's all they look good on camera
although I do like I I did buy some like
from Amazon that are short yeah and
those are actually like a lot better as
long as you like glue them on like
you're not like worried about them
constantly like snapping off all the
time you can actually do things with
them on but the long ones absolutely you
can yeah I have my wigs for your fingers
they are I'm at the point where I just
[ __ ] say [ __ ] shave it all off and
[ __ ] I'll put a wig on to become
dancing
yeah yeah I'm just saying like I said if
you already asked me to put a wig on
today they don't [ __ ] slap y'all are
[ __ ] slack you wouldn't do it anyway
well that's the thing I've been [ __ ]
people ask people ask you and you won't
do it so everybody just probably said
well we're not even gonna ask you
anymore why are you crying why are you
crying
you've been getting all like cranky
about it
you didn't look dude we even did a live
stream about Jaws four like jaws of
Revenge and you didn't even put the
Michael Kane wig on
I can't believe that [ __ ] I can't
believe it you have you just like you
just people asked you to do it and you
were just like yeah I'm not doing it
I'm back in Danzig mode
it's a little bit crooked but it's
crooked and it's loose
well that's what you need to like you
know there's like a little clip back
there it's good back there but I don't
have time for that [ __ ] I don't have
time I don't usually put it on like
we're on the show because it gives me a
headache but I'll put it on if I'm going
out so it doesn't like slide off but I'm
gonna wear this to the club one of these
days people will [ __ ] trip out
wouldn't it they would probably think it
was hilarious they wouldn't like they
wouldn't recognize me probably not well
that's what happened like the first few
times I went out with this blue wig on I
think people like a bunch of my friends
like just walked right by me they didn't
recognize you and then like every now
and then people like oh it's you I mean
it is dark in there to be fair
um so yeah
so she had an idea for fake fingernails
and John Hague saying hey I'm an
engineer maybe I can help you out
without the Prototype right so she's
like okay fair enough like yeah why
don't you come to my like Workshop
office thing that looked I mean it
looked like a [ __ ] to be honest it
looked like a workshop it didn't look
like yeah
so she goes down there and she's like
looking at some [ __ ] and he shoots on
the back of that
uh with a and this actually said like
what gun it was a 38 caliber Webley
Revolver because I know you care about
that kind of stuff what kind of was it
38 caliber Webley oh British revolver uh
breaks open
yeah and uh this was a gun that he'd
actually stolen from his former victim
yeah so you know utilizing all the stuff
that he took and he used that to like
shoot her then he took all her [ __ ] uh
she had like a really expensive uh fur
coat so took that and uh took all of her
jewelry and all that other kind of stuff
and then put her in the Acid Bath yeah
webleies were good they were good
um
for you movie Buffs
um
what's his name [ __ ] um Indiana Jones
used the 45 Webley
in one of those movies we'll be shooting
it I think that was part three where
he's shooting at the damn fighter plane
it was coming at him it was a 45 Webley
yeah just old British classic British
revolver
gone now big you know by today's
standards but you know just what it it
was what it was
they're asking you to put on a wig now
the curly wig
what curly weight they talking about
wait who are your diamonds put the curly
wig on
she's not changed the wig that's her
that wig is set up for tonight look how
beautiful she looks that palette skin
and that blue hair she looks like an ice
princess
or honky Ice Princess I am an ice
princess yeah yeah
I the only curly wig I have well no the
only actual curly wig I have is that red
one that I wore when I was Amy from
Fright Night yeah which I haven't I
don't or you know I I guess if I dress
up like brave from that from that Pixar
movie that was Pixar movie right uh then
then yeah that would that would be that
but that's it's ironic because that
Curly my hair is not curly but um that
wig is actually very close to my actual
hair color before I started dyeing it
except now like my hair is probably gray
because I'm old but uh but yeah
so he killed this old lady and dissolved
her an acid again now two days after
that a friend of hers reported her
missing
now apparently there was some kind of
like suspicion about John Hague maybe
because uh you know Olive had been seen
with him like not too long before she
disappeared so the cops start looking
into the [ __ ]
and obviously he has a criminal record
because he had all those fraud
convictions right so they're just like
huh well that's interesting we're gonna
look into this [ __ ]
so they search his Workshop
what do they find in there
they find
this dude's so [ __ ] stupid
they find he had like an attache case in
there
in the attache case there was a dry
cleaning receipt for the fur coat that
he had stolen from Olive who you will
remember just was dissolved in acid two
days earlier
also there was some paperwork in there
that referred to both the Hendersons the
couple that he killed and the mcswans
three of them three of whom he had
killed the whole family you're off
screen no no no no I'm not you're on
screen here okay
yeah what's funny is that that well
that's just because the chat window oh
okay it's a chat window okay yeah it's
always been something that you it's
always been like okay just checking yeah
it's a I have to hold it over there so I
can see the notes on that you know the
screen that's not the true that's not
the true camera with no no no no all
right like I said there's some of it
like underneath there it's just I have
to I can see the chat like this [ __ ]
looks fine fine I actually see the chat
drunk getting confused I guess so yeah
let's just try out the wigs are they
wanted Michael Kane wig I have so I have
so many wigs in there you guys
yeah like the curl it like I said I have
a red curly one and I have a couple like
I have a couple that are like wavy I
have like a dark blue wavy one and I
have what's that other wavy one I have a
red wavy one yeah but the wavy ones
don't look as good I think the straight
ones look a little bit better although I
haven't worn that red curly one in a
long time
but yeah so he has like a bunch of
paperwork relating to like several
people that he killed
so because as I mentioned this Workshop
that he rented didn't have a drain like
his old place did
it he so he was just dumping
the people sludge into the back
like garbage pile like in the backyard
essentially and he thought that like no
one was gonna [ __ ]
figure that out I guess I can't imagine
so the cops start looking through this
particular garbage area
and find
28 pounds of human body fat
and also 28 pounds also part of that
foot remember I said that Dr Henderson's
foot didn't
um didn't dissolve yeah they found a
foot
in the pile Hugo I couldn't find the
Michael King wig she's got a [ __ ] ton in
there I have knocked over a little thing
of wigs I had to put them up you'll fix
it later yeah yeah thanks yeah
her [ __ ] closet has gotten more and
more complicated with stuff it's not
complicated okay it's got all the wigs
all the way the wigs that I wear most of
the time are just like just laying right
there the ones that I don't wear is
often I have them on their wig stands
like up on the hangers but they're
asking for a cuckoo con drink shirt
I don't know man I made one for the
Zazzle store yeah okay there is one on
there there's one on Zazzle because
because that has to be full color yeah
the shirts that they're normally
normally you know real popular or
something having to do with movies and
culture and uh
that are kind of universal I'm gonna put
the 13 o'clock kind of spin on it like
it's an exclusive that we sell that
that's what really kind of what I like
to do
I really want to come up with a predator
one shirt yeah you just said that yeah
that's I just got to figure it out what
would be the best way to do that yeah I
think it would be popular if we got it
right
well when I have time I'll research it
Cannon and Carol Kohler going good
because they have to do with Studios
that some of the best B movies Our
Generation grew up with and you all are
appreciating them I like that those are
seven
yeah so where was I 28 pounds of body
fat uh a partial foot
also found some gallstones I think
that's what I remembered more than
anything because acid doesn't dissolve
the gallstones so they found a bunch of
gallstones and they found part of some
Dentures which belonged to Olive the
last old lady that he killed so
he didn't do like a real thorough job
gonna say hey I'm gonna dissolve these
people and acid oh but what's a foot or
a gallstone here I'm just gonna dump it
in the backyard it'll be fine in the
people sludge nobody'll ever know
so they bring this [ __ ] in there
was actually like a great I can't
remember what the name of the show is
but there's like a Great British crime
show that has like uh it does like a lot
of these old cases and does reenactments
of them and the reenactment they did of
John Hague was just it was classic where
he's just like sitting there and he's
all like super smug and everything like
that like well you guys don't have a
body blah blah it's like a foot that's
like pretty uh you know what I mean
that's kind of suspicious
so
let me think because there wasn't like a
body body
then
he couldn't be like convicted like he
really did seem to genuinely think that
so they questioned him for a long time
the cops are basically like yeah okay
and then at one point he asked the cops
what are the chances of anybody being
released from Broadmoor which we did a
show about Broadmoor did we not very
very famous uh you know familiar it's an
insane asylum yeah yeah it's where like
the criminally insane but that's where
they put the criminal team
so he straight up asked the cops
what are the chances of anybody being
released from Broadmoor
uh the inspector said yeah I'm not going
to tell you that kind of thing
and uh John Hague is like well if I told
you the truth you wouldn't believe me it
sounds too fantastic to believe he then
proceeds to confess everything
he says I killed Olive dran Deacon I
killed all the mcswans I killed the
Hendersons I killed three other people
that you [ __ ] don't even know
about
um and we I mean we don't know the other
three they're not sure but like they're
pretty sure about like the other six
and he thought it seemed he felt like
comfortable confessing because he
thought well there weren't any bodies
so even if he confessed
then they couldn't do anything to him
and I think the cops just thought it was
like kind of funny so they just like
sort of just let him talk
because they're like okay if he thinks
that we're just gonna like let him
[ __ ] think that you know what I mean
holy [ __ ] so he just like [ __ ]
blabbed yeah I just I shot this dude and
I dissolved him an acid and and then he
like had all kind of tips about oh the
first time I did it it was kind of
[ __ ] up like I didn't even have a mask
or anything like that so I had to figure
it out for the next time and the cops
were just sitting there going okay and
they're just like oh [ __ ] I know
what I mean he's so [ __ ] stupid but
the cops were just probably like yeah go
on I said before if you have basic field
dressing skills and Butchery skills in a
bathtub you could avoid all this [ __ ]
but these [ __ ] are cowards and
overthinking [ __ ] they're [ __ ] dumb
dumb it's not hard to deal with just
[ __ ] Google on YouTube or just look
on YouTube how to field dress a deer how
to Pro and how to clean a deer
there's no difference between that and
Hammond they just don't want to do the
work and they're thinking wrong they
just think it's wrong
dumb
yeah I mean just I mean the thing about
it like I said who would think
that dissolving people in acid and like
it wasn't even like completely dissolved
like I said there were still gallstones
and feet and dentures and stuff and then
he's just like [ __ ] it I'll just like
dump it in the backyard it'll be fine no
one will suspects something like
no one will suspect a thing something
tells me that that kills me that they're
that these are not Hands-On people and
they're afraid to deal with dead bodies
of animals or humans which that goes
into the this is food industry skills
if you have anything to do with the food
industry you're going to be dealing with
the bodies of animals there's no
difference in antibodies in animals and
humans the only difference is
psychological it's just in your mind
it's the same thing
it's that same skill set no special
equipment required a three inch curved
skinning blade can take a [ __ ] elk
down into small portable clean little
packaged parts that you could sell at a
dam
grocery store a three inch blade can do
that
I heard some of these dudes in the past
saying well I went and I got the
chainsaw
what chainsaw what the [ __ ] are you
talking about that shit's gonna splatter
everywhere
you ever seen a Chainsaw cut through a
[ __ ] log it sends [ __ ] wood
fragments all over the [ __ ] place
with sawdust it's gonna do the same
thing to that meat
a [ __ ] simple blade three inch curved
very sharp that's all you need
just [ __ ] ridiculous
you know well like I said everybody
they're dumbasses everybody thinks that
they're they found a hack yeah I kind of
feel like that's yeah that was a special
way yeah that's what I mean nobody ever
thought of this ever yeah and this is
the best way to do it like I said
everybody loves a hack that nobody's
ever thought of and I kind of feel like
this that's the same situation yeah
that's the same there's no special
science to this you it's
you get frustrated
and then some of them are just [ __ ]
criminals and they're they're in the
common criminals [ __ ] dumb
okay and they're imagining an obstacle
that is that is not there okay there's
nothing special about any of this
you know
processing a body
it's done every day in every [ __ ]
butcher shop in every [ __ ] kitchen
sometimes we have a whole [ __ ] tuna
delivered
internal organs were out of it but
that's the same as cleaning any oil fish
like a trout
and it's just part of the food
processing problem and uh a human would
apply right to that same
skill set wouldn't matter
not to be weird it might be better to
eat the human uh depending on the
circumstances
I mean just I'm just saying if you're if
you've already gone that far
some guys have done it I wouldn't do it
unless my life depended on if you're in
a starvation situation well I wouldn't
either I'm just saying hypothetically
I'm just saying if you're if you've
already gotten to the point where it's
like hey I'm gonna shoot a [ __ ]
and dissolve an acid it's like you might
as well just cook them and eat them I
think that would probably be better okay
look man I don't want to teach a
[ __ ] or anything as far as like
eliminating evidence I'm just saying I
do not want to teach anybody anything
stay with all animals
for safety reasons it doesn't matter if
it's a human or any other animals stay
away from internal organs in general
that's where the problem is regular meat
flesh is a lot safer
cannibals can come down with [ __ ] like
Kuru and all kinds and and but they're
eating brains and internal organs
because in the cultures where
cannibalism happens
they don't have an aversion to internal
organs internal organs are for poor
people let's be honest uh yeah there are
poor people in the south there are poor
people in England they're eating kidney
pie and all this other [ __ ] if you're
eating internal organs you're poor
uh stay away from that
um
in humans it's worse the the dangers
okay eating internal organs
that's just a survival tip okay that's
not for practical knowledge it's just if
you're if you're trapped like say on top
of a mountain with a bunch of dead
bodies and you're starving like it
happened up in Argentina back in the 70s
if you if you're forced to eat people to
survive dead people to survive stay away
from the internal organs
um
same thing with animals stay away from
internal organs it's too risky
only eat that [ __ ] if you're [ __ ]
starving
and if you're forced to enter if you're
forced to eat internal organs
the safest internal organ to eat is the
heart
the rest of that shit's dangerous in
general
livers kidneys no
no
stomachs there's not much there
lungs terrible don't eat that
nothing in the intestines don't [ __ ]
with that there's too many possibility
of parasites and all kinds of problems
throw all that [ __ ] out unless you're
[ __ ] starving to death
Rebecca said I get this is off topic but
I need to ask as it's mid-morning here
and I have to keep going Jenny do you
have uh books or have seen a documentary
about the gang rape torture murder of
Anita Kobe I have not she says asking
for a reason I have not but I have
written it down so I will look it up for
later
uh Camp guy said calves liver with
onions is good yeah my grandma used to
eat that all the time I'm not a big
liver fan yeah I have eaten it but it's
not really it has to be prepared rightly
it's not correctly it's risky in the
wild okay I don't mind it if it's mixed
in with other things because you've made
like gravy at Thanksgiving that had
Livery yeah I use is okay but that's
those are domestic animals yeah okay
that have come out of the American food
system in the wild
and that includes
people in a cannibalism
bare bottom situation don't eat brains
don't eat that don't eat brains either
that's all dangerous you're gonna get
mad cat or Kuru Kuru
like somebody said earlier yeah John
goris said yeah you're gonna get too
much risk
yeah it's it's just not worth it yeah
Wild game I've hunted lots of wild game
venison fish and everything all the
internal organs are thrown out you don't
know where that deer has been
and those are the highest risks we
didn't even eat dare heart and dear
heart would be safe but there's just not
much there now if I was gonna make some
kind of gravy I'd use that heart but we
were never making gravy
choices part on the [ __ ] deer is the
is the the filet which goes along the
spine and the hind quarters there's
really not much in the shoulder or the
front quarter there's not much meat
there
everything and even not much on the neck
it's just very
thin pieces of tough meat it was just
all thrown away
you know you don't get much out of a
deer even though it's a pretty big
animal
it's just very lean very tough
very thin pieces of meat they're not
very thick
so you get two hindquarters and
basically the deer version of filet
mignon that runs along the back of the
Spy the rest of it's
there's just not much mass there once
he's cleaned out
10 pounds 20 pounds or nothing really
not counting bones
send you you know
cartilage and not cartilage but it's
mostly sinew
which is like eating [ __ ] pieces of
[ __ ] plastic or you might as well
chew on it down
bow string or [ __ ] the strings of a
[ __ ] Batman racket you know there's
not much there
Rebecca says I will send the best
something oh thank you one of the most
horrific crimes in all of Australian
criminal history okay
I'm looking forward to that in like a
weird way xanadas said my Italian
Grandma used to make gravy out of the
eyes and hearts of animals usually
turkey I never ate it they're probably
probably uh yeah yeah yeah Isabella said
any serving suggestions like for human
or
on your average human the only thing
that would be worth eating would be the
the leg and the butt yeah the rest of it
there wouldn't be much there on the
average human
I kind of feel like yeah maybe a calf
there there's a few pounds there
other than that yeah no I just kind of
feel like every person doesn't have much
on their arms they don't have much on
the pectoral the chest muscles it's just
and you the rest of those internal
organs would be risky I wouldn't eat
that human butt roast yeah
they say hands were good
the people that survived some plant
grass the hands tasted like bacon
because there was a lot of fat in them
tell people that
chewing on hands this it was like bacon
my hand but they basically taste like
pork
yeah I've heard that the Vikings called
human beings long pork the Vikings were
also cannibals people don't realize that
but they would keep
they called uh
Fallen enemies you know because they
were on battlefields they're like well
don't waste that and they'd pull up an
enemy and they'd eat them you know and
they called it long pork or long Pig
well I mean as long as they're dead they
were already dead there's guys were
killed in combat Meats meat you don't
want to you know they didn't want to
waste a dead body sitting there
practical they were just like get that
we'll delete that we'll eat that dude's
butt yeah
Santa just said Albert Fish ate the butt
yeah he did yeah that's where all the
meat is
well yeah I'm just gonna say like from a
practical standpoint if you ever have to
eat a human like hopefully nobody's in a
situation where you have to eat a human
but if you do like uh I kind of feel
like the butt and the thigh are the only
things you want to eat so yeah
how did that happen I don't really know
how we get off on these [ __ ] tangents
but
I I guess I don't wonder I know I know
how but like I said so the cops come in
and they search the rubble pile like I
said they find 28 pounds of human fat so
you know uh all the gallstones I think
they found three of them they found the
uh the foot part of the foot a bunch of
bone fragments actually so that didn't
dissolve
uh and they found some dentures and then
they also found like some other stuff
that wasn't like body related so they
found like you know part of a purse and
like part of like a lipstick tube and
[ __ ] like that
so uh despite all this despite all the
evidence that they found and like I said
even though this is the 40s and like
forensic science isn't like the greatest
and stuff but obviously they're like
well clearly uh people have died here
but for whatever reason John Hague still
thinks well technically there's no body
so you guys can't do anything so they
said like when he came into court he was
just like totally he was just like yeah
what's up you know what I mean like like
he thought he was gonna get away with it
like I'm totally beating this rap
because there's no body wait till they
find out that it was kind of like that
like I said he he kind of thought he
knew more than everybody else
so yeah so he comes in and I don't know
if that was just because he literally he
legitimately thought that because there
wasn't a whole body that he would get
away with it or if he was just that much
of a sociopath that he didn't really
give a [ __ ] if he went to jail or not I
don't know
so uh and like I said at this point like
when he goes in when he goes to trial
he's already confessed to everything
like in great detail
so I don't really know like why he
thought
why he thought he was going to get away
with it but they said that he really did
seem that he was going to get away with
it
but what happened though and this is why
he asked about Broadmoor but the reason
that he asked about Broadmoor was one of
the reasons that they didn't let him get
away with it is because his defense
attorney was like okay we're going for
an insanity plea
so that was why he started saying the
stuff like after he asked the cops about
like you know what happens if you get an
insanity defense or can people get out
abroad more and after that he started
like embellishing stuff it's that's when
he started like the whole drinking the
blood thing
that's why I think he didn't really
drink the blood from the victims because
I think he only added that detail on
there to make him seem crazier
so that he would just get sent to Broad
Broadmoor where he was hoping that he
would get out of there at some point
like instead of going to prison or going
to the [ __ ] Gallows
so he also like talked about those weird
dreams that he had which like I said I
don't know if he really had those or if
he was just like making stuff up to make
him sound crazier I kind of suspect it's
the latter
so basically though uh the prosecution
had over 30 Witnesses
uh that you know could say that yeah he
premeditated the [ __ ] now to get an
insanity defense is not an easy thing
like it's not as easy as people think
even back in the 40s basically you had
to have a thing where is this person
aware that what they're doing is bad
you know what I mean and if you still
know that what you're doing is bad and
wrong and [ __ ] like that then obviously
you're not crazy because you still have
a moral compass
as much as he's like yeah I drank these
people's blood and like came up with all
these weird dreams and stuff people were
able like all these Witnesses and stuff
like that and all of the paper you know
the kind of the paper trail that he'd
laughed and [ __ ] like that they were
very much able to say well he very
meticulously planned all these crimes
like he forged all these letters like he
forged people's signatures like to get
their money and stuff like that so he
did it was very very uh there was a lot
of forethought involved and obviously
that is not conducive to an insanity
defense
so the prosecution brought in a whole
bunch of like doctors and psychologists
and all that kind of stuff and all of
them like talked to this [ __ ]
and they're basically like yeah he's
just like pretending that he drank blood
because he wants to seem crazy so he can
go to Broadmoor instead of going to
prison or getting executed uh they said
he absolutely knew what he was doing
um and all that stuff is probably just
[ __ ]
now what they tried to come up with
um they said
they did think that he had mental health
issues obviously
but that he wasn't insane by the legal
defense like he still knew what he was
doing was was bad and that he was very
aware and they said well you know the
very fact that he tried to cover up the
stuff by dissolving the bodies uh would
seem to say that he knew that it was
wrong and that he would get in trouble
if he got caught
um one psychiatrist said that he had
what they called a paranoid Constitution
which is the same mental disease that
Hitler had actually
um they thought this is what the
psychiatrist that examine and thought
they thought that he had developed
paranoia like this kind of like paranoid
personality because of the way that he
was brought up uh because of this weird
very isolated like religious uh kind of
belief system that his parents raised
him in and that he was uh again like
very isolated very lonely and he was
just kind of like had a thing where he
couldn't really discern like maybe
reality from fantasy and once he got to
a point too when he was a little bit
older and figured out that his parents
were like bullshitting and like making
up a bunch of stuff he got to a point
where he thought that he could just like
get away with anything too so there was
that also I wouldn't put much weight
into old-fashioned psychology all right
what he's talking about doesn't exist
foreign
I would go more for the newer stuff and
it's the same thing about all mustache
man if you actually look at the details
there wasn't
really anything wrong with them per se
other than
third stage syphilis had a lot to do
with some of the [ __ ] oh Hitler did
towards the end of his life that had a
lot to do with it he had neurological
problems but it wasn't psychological in
the way that these guys think that
well I mean and the thing about it too
is that you can have mental issues but
that doesn't mean you're crazy or you're
not competent or anything like that like
insanity I mean that's that has a very
specific legal definition
um and it's very very hard to meet it
you can have all kinds of like mental
health issues but that doesn't mean that
you're allowed to like commit crimes
Willy and like you didn't know what you
were doing was bad when it comes to
mustache man people that knew him
in his early political career said that
he was nothing that the man at the end
of his life was nothing like that and
what they described syphilis that's what
happened to him well a lot of people
thought probably like weird Sage
syphilis will give you late stage
syphilis does a lot of [ __ ] and one and
a lot of think okay one of the main
things about late stage syphilis
it gives you a very robotic lizard-like
manners it's like you're an artificial
human and another thing is is that it
syphilis does to you
it's called syphilis in remission or
late stage syphilis once you
once you've decided on something you
cannot reverse your decision
which that's that's mustache man right
there
once he committed forces to Operation
Barbarossa and lost them in Russia he
could not Retreat he could not turn
around he couldn't come back from
anything
they also call that the sunk cost fast
right yeah yeah he was one of those
uh but other than that there was nothing
unusual about that guy and that's what a
lot of people don't want to hear I've
been studying that dude off and on since
I was a little kid why'd he do that what
was this dude really like
there was nothing special about him he
was an average dude other than that
syphilis
and the situation that he was in and a
lot of people had syphilis back yeah a
lot of people had a lot and people don't
want to hear that because they want some
explanation
well and that's not the way life is I
think it's the same thing with serial
killers people are always like they
expect them to be monsters or they can't
act like normal people but some of them
can yeah and that's what's scary like
sometimes it's just like a normal ass
person yeah he was a normal ass dude
around a bunch of other normal dudes
that were thinking a certain thing it
was like a culture it was a mass [ __ ]
movement okay
of and it became very cult-like over
time and it was group thick and it and
uh they [ __ ] painted themselves into
a corner and they were doing [ __ ] that a
decade prior they would have never done
but there's an insanity to crowds and
that's what happened there
um and if you were to ask them what was
going on they thought they were saving
the world they thought they were the
good guys
they had just
talked themselves into something that
was unwinnable
no
were they crazy no but people wanted it
people don't want to hear that
they want to hear some kind of
explanation that frees them from the
possibility of that of ever happening to
them oh no that could happen to you too
well in a way that's why I'm fascinated
by that kind of stuff I'm fascinated by
normal seeming around people who go off
on that kind of thing because it's like
you have to be aware yeah that that
could absolutely happen to anybody I'm
not saying that anybody could be a
serial killer no that's a different
situation but I'm just saying that
anybody anybody could commit murder big
time like if the circumstances were
correct when you have millions of people
that seemingly agree on something you're
in a paradigm where you feel that you
have to agree with it too that's what
happened to them
like the extreme peer pressure
and then you have a [ __ ] political
philosophy that transforms itself
basically into a religion you know and
they just could not reverse any of their
decisions so mustache man wasn't alone
he was caught up
in that same movement and he was a
perfect figurehead for it because
of the syphilis that he had
there was no way he could reverse what
he was doing and stop everyone else or
he would have lost popularity it was
just
has to do with mass psychology
what do they call it
Mass formation mass mass psychosis
formation I think is what the word that
they use to describe it
and it could happen to anybody and any
Mass it could happen
on the right the left the religious the
secular the atheists that could happen
to anybody that's why humans are like
schools of fish you got to be careful
don't follow the crowd all the time
the crowd could be handed right over a
[ __ ] cliff
Danny Rowling said was this killer
executed or do you just rotten a jail
cell and die he was executed which I'm
which I was about to get to but spoiler
alert
so uh so yeah so he goes to trial in
1949
thousands and thousands people show up
to see this because like I said this is
a big famous case
now at this point John Hague uh had
blowing all the money that he stole from
the people that he dissolved in acid so
he didn't have any money to pay for his
defense
so uh the news of the World newspaper
said hey we'll pay for your defense if
you give us an exclusive like all the
salacious details of what you did so he
said he would do that
uh there was also a thing too where you
know the Daily Mirror which is actually
like still in uh it's kind of like a rag
you know what I mean like a tabloid but
um they got in trouble because they
actually referred to him as a murderer
like before the trial was over like
instead of saying like alleged murderer
that's what you're supposed to say
because technically he's not guilty so
they got like a contempt to court for
that and had to pay like a huge fee I
just thought that was interesting
Jeffrey R says Tom is is frustrated with
the ineptitude of today's psychos yes I
am
but it is a psycho is going to do what a
psycho does those [ __ ] are dumb
half of them well the thing about it is
like if they weren't psychos like their
thought process with processes would be
a lot clearer and maybe they wouldn't
have like all these dumbass ideas it's
just frustrating to see somebody who
airs so much you know you're just like
what the [ __ ] you think but like I said
they're serial killers so like don't
help them let them be stupid then
they'll get caught yeah you know what
I'm saying like don't let him run around
right so John Hague his arrogant ass he
comes into the trial like he pleads not
guilty not guilty you guys don't have a
body
yeah we got a foot and 28 pounds of
human fat though and teeth and stuff
okay that's kind of a body uh so yeah so
the prosecution comes in like I said
they had numerous witnesses that said
that he had uh you know obviously
defrauded a bunch of people and like
faked a bunch of letters and stuff like
that was super super suspicious
uh so the defense pretty much all they
had was like he's crazy he drinks blood
all this other kind of [ __ ] like I said
uh the psychiatrist like yeah he's not
crazy he's just like trying to [ __ ]
[ __ ] pull some [ __ ]
um so and you know like I said the the
prosecution also pointed out like if he
was crazy he wouldn't have tried to like
dissolve the bodies and assets like
cover up the crimes clearly so he
obviously knew what he was doing was
wrong
so you know it I don't even know how
long the trial lasted but they were just
kind of like yeah and then one of the
cops came forward and said yeah he legit
like asked me about Broadmoor and then
started saying all the stuff about blood
drinking so it seemed like very
calculated
so basically
um the jury goes and they're just kind
of like well
you know what are you guys and they're
just like yeah dude hang the
[ __ ] come on you know what I
mean he's not crazy uh 15 minutes it
took the jury 15 minutes to come back
with a guilty verdict
the judge says to John Hague uh do you
have anything to say for yourself and he
just like went all arrogant said nothing
at all he said and then uh the judge
says well we're gonna hang your ass
that's you know I'm paraphrasing that's
not what he actually said now so John
Hague he actually
um gave his life story to the newspaper
like that had paid for the trial
uh he wrote letters to his parents I
would love to know what his parents
thought about this whole situation did
they like blame themselves maybe
probably not probably not like did they
really think that they had contributed
to how their son had turned out
I wonder I don't know but uh yeah he
wrote down and he wrote to his
girlfriend and his girlfriend his
girlfriend was like really upset about
it because she didn't realize I guess
that he was a serial killer and she
asked him I think at one point like
Point Blank like would you have killed
me
and he's just like nah nah of course not
but she was just kind of like you kind
of paused there though I kind of feel
like maybe if I got in the way or if I
won the lottery or something probably
you would I could he probably would have
so yeah
so basically uh so yeah so he's going to
The Gallows now he told his girlfriend
that he suddenly I don't know if this is
suddenly he believed in reincarnation
and he said I'm gonna come back and
complete my mission his mission being
to kill people and dissolve into acid
and take all their money evidently so he
thought that he was going to come back
in his next life and do that [ __ ] okay
that didn't happen I don't think
um Madame Tussauds Wax wax museum which
is actually cool if you've never been
there I've been there they have and
obviously they're kind of chamber of
Horrors is the best part
they uh said hey can we do a death mask
after you get uh hanged and he was just
like sure you know what I mean so yeah
so they did a death mask so he got
hanged yeah 1949. uh hanged at
Wandsworth prison Madame Tussauds did a
wax figure of him and he even
gave them like he like in his will he
gave them like his actual clothes so
they could put the actual clothes on the
wax figure
so yeah so I don't I remember I think I
saw that actually I wasn't I went to
Madame tussa I was back in
2000 and like in the 2000s like the mid
to late 2000s sometime and I I think
they did have a John but I don't really
remember it I don't remember that
particular figure I remember the one
they had of uh Crippen I remember that
one
like down in the chamber of Horrors I
think they did have him there but yeah
that was his actual clothes that he
bequeathed to the museum which okay I
kind of Wonder like though
what was he thinking when he was
actually like standing there did he
think man I'm pretty stupid I should
have like
I should have done things differently
I wondered anything that
I don't know because
what an idiot seriously what an idiot
I don't know
John Gore said he aspired spider comes
solvent by dissolving others
that's pretty good actually that's
pretty good so I can't believe it we
made it through the show we did well
what do you mean we always make a
candidate we always make it well most of
the time most of the time we do all
right so uh is there uh you guys have
any questions about the case or any
questions about the show if not then
we'll check off soon and I'll make
something to eat you hungry yeah start
okay
what time is it oh it's still early yeah
it's it's only 8 30. yeah like I said
it's only we've only been on for two and
a half it was a good chance man it's a
good show well like I said I'm glad that
this was one this was the case I've been
wanting to do a long time and two it's
only one dude so it's not like super
complicated okay so you want to have a
little after party or do you want to uh
yeah we'll do a little after okay
uh sure okay I'll make you need another
drink yeah we're gonna have like it's
after party time okay so what does
everybody think about this [ __ ]
I mean
I don't know why this guy in particular
because
here's the thing I was a morbid kid you
guys like right I started reading
scary stories I started reading about
serial killers and stuff like that like
very young age it's like I'm fine I
didn't you know
and for whatever reason this guy
really like stuck in my head I think I
was fascinated by like morbidly
fascinated by the whole dissolving and
acid thing
because I told you before that even when
I was a kid I was really really weirded
out and also like simultaneously
fascinated by dismemberment particularly
beheading that was like it really like
it scared me but I was also like really
really fascinated by it and I always and
I would think about it a lot like what
how long are you alive like after your
head gets cut up like are you aware that
your head gets cut off and like I said
that scene in The Omen you know what I
mean like where David Warner's like head
gets cut off by the pain of glass I said
just like hypothetically if that
happened in real life like would you
actually like feel your [ __ ] head and
be like super light and be like flying
through it like that fascinated me but
also like [ __ ] me up at the same time
I had to add a little bit of OJ in there
it's great though well that's okay I
like OJ I like that better than the yeah
than the other stuff because that other
juices well it's not even juice but it's
like it's almost like it's kind of like
um acidic it's like really really sour
it's like tart
but yeah so I was always fascinated by
that and I so by extension I think that
I was fascinated by not only like bodily
dismemberment but also like bodily
you know disillusion so if somebody was
like dissolving about I was just like
man that's [ __ ] up like it's like
weird to think about like this body that
you live in and then suddenly somebody
puts you in a barrel and then you're
just like a bunch of sludge and a foot
you know what I mean or a bunch of
sludge of like a gallstone and like I
got I was really weirded out by that so
I wrote I read about this guy like when
I was probably God I must have been like
only 10 or 11 or something like that it
was like a true crime book that I had
and that that case this case in
particular like really really stuck in
my head for whatever reason I was just
like fascinated by people being
dissolved
Zach said I mean he just threw the foot
in the garden like that's what I mean
like what the [ __ ] how
arrogant do you have to be
how much smarter than the police do you
have to be you come back into your
workshop and I'm just you know I'm just
spitballing I'm saying this is probably
what happened he comes back into the
workshop and he's like oh [ __ ] like that
one foot wasn't all the way in the acid
or for whatever reason it didn't
disintegrate although ah [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
it's fine I'll just dump it out like
with all the others no one will notice a
foot surely it's just
I don't know why that just [ __ ] kills
me like it's funny but it's like it's
not funny you know what I mean I don't
know that's that's the kind of [ __ ] that
like that's the kind of [ __ ] up sense
of humor I have I guess
I mean [ __ ] xanadas said I have a female
friend who also says she's fascinated by
this case I don't know what it is
I think it's just the whole bodily
disillusion thing oh it's fun it's kind
of it's kind of samey to me well now I
mean anything anything that has to do
with like the human body as meat
um is fascinating to me
I'm not really sure why like or for
whatever reason it just like sticks in
my head so anything to do with like
dismemberment or you know dissolving or
anything like that I'm always just like
really into that but and also this also
had the added thing of like which I
brought up before like [ __ ]
that I hate is just like dudes that do
[ __ ] like this but like think they're
smarter than everybody and it's like
well obviously I can just like kill all
the people I want and I can like I can
even like tell you that I killed the
people he's like yeah I killed that
[ __ ] but you don't have a body
so you can't like can't prove it and
they're just like yep there's a foot
though right in your backyard so and a
whole bunch of human fat that came from
somewhere right so yeah so I don't
really know like what he thought that's
why I really wish for a second that I
could get inside this dude's head well
while he was on The Gallows and where
he's like man I done [ __ ] up probably
I should have gone about this in a more
in a smarter way I don't know
I don't know but uh yeah so we had
another drink we're having an after
party yeah party it's only 8 30. I'm
thinking about
um what we're gonna cook
you know I have all that let's talk
about food I have all that [ __ ] um
Japanese [ __ ] fake crab I got two of
them sealed down there he wants crab
salad one of these days hell yeah okay I
like that you got you got that at Sam's
for me right I got two of it sounds for
you the thing about that because you
don't like it much no I like it I eat it
and but I like it I like that fake crab
the only thing I don't like about that
fake crab is that you can't heat it
it doesn't work on anything that's
[ __ ] cooked although well okay when
the Chinese try to those Chinese
restaurants try to pass it off as
something because it's not as good it's
best cold
it is but it's okay like a few times
when we've been to uh koiwan yeah they
have like they make it like on big sheet
pans yeah and it's the fake crab and
it's like other kind of fish and like
some cheese and like some other kind of
stuff and that's pretty good what was it
exactly maybe I can make that
um I don't remember it's been a while
since I've had it but they make it
unless sheet pan it's the crab what they
call it oh I don't know maybe people in
the comment section might know what
she's talking about I know that it's
like crab there's something else in
there it's maybe like some kind of
vegetable maybe it's celery I can't
really remember but then there's like a
like a layer of cheese like melted on
top of it it's like a sheet pan I
thought it had cheese and crumble of
some sort oh I don't know if it has
crumble on it it does cheese like I said
it's been a while maybe
you're trying to Imagine John Gore said
how is it fake well it's only fake
because it's not fish crab but it's
still fish it's not like it's fake like
it's made of like [ __ ] old phone
books or something it's fake crap
crab it's fish It's Not crab
it's [ __ ]
fish but it tastes crabby that was
ground up in a centrifuge
okay and then
pulled out of that centrifuged and
cooked
in a shape that and flavored to make it
be like a crab like product it's spelled
with a K not C
that's not crab that's fish
it's close enough yeah that's what I
mean the problem with it is that if you
cook it it falls apart it turns into
flaky stuff and you're like wait hold on
I actually like this I actually like the
sushi that's made with that because a
while back remember you made like some
sushi with those sticks and avocado and
something else I can't remember what
else you put in there but it was good I
I checked the history on crab with the
cake
and it was never designed it was never
engineered
in it's it's from Japan it is Japanese
it was never engineered to be heated
it was engineered to be
to be served cold
on sushi
yeah I kind of thought that was the
whole reason for it existing yeah it was
never really supposed to be hot it was
for sushi rolls it was for sushi rolls
and you've made it and you made sushi
with it before which is delicious yeah
it's great on sushi rolls it is yeah but
there are some times where you're like
man I wish I had a hot crab meal
you know but you you don't have crab on
hand or crabs real expensive crab can be
real expensive even here in Florida
in the can it's not too bad yeah if I
can remember the time we had this crab
legs if I can Win Dixie yeah they were a
good sale man they were [ __ ]
outstanding and we went in there one
time we were all golfed out we asked for
some crab legs they had them Frozen
and the girl working said look I got a
bunch of crab legs that need to be
thrown at them because they're too small
I'm gonna give them to you so we got
like two pounds of we paid for two
pounds or three pounds of crab legs and
she gave us like six pounds
remember the little [ __ ] we made a
crab boil yeah damn
that was the goth bonus
because that girl working with me I'm
gonna hook you guys up these are gonna
be thrown out anyway because he's
pulling them off their eyes and we were
nice to her we were not yeah which like
I said you get you actually get a lot by
being like super nice to people that
work in stores and stuff yeah if you get
in with if you be a dick they're not
gonna give you nothing they're gonna
spit in your food if you get in with
those gross if you get in with those
Grocers they'll hook you up
the ones that are [ __ ] cutting stuff
and surfing stuff up like I got more of
this hold on hold on this is going to go
out anyway it'll give you more
I've always gotten I've always gotten
like a lot more stuff by being like
super nice to people don't like complain
to people they don't like don't be a
Karen don't be a Karen Karen
um yeah Danny Rowling said who is
smarter Dahmer or this guy
Dahmer Dahmer problem Dahmer yeah I'm
that's my first instinct Dahmer wasn't
too bright either but I think he was
smarter than this idiot yeah
Zach says speaking of food I'm a boredom
eater which is why I've been so fat
lately got any ideas on how I could stop
that honestly what I've had to do
because I'm kind of in the same boat
and I know this might not work for
everybody and it's hard for me to but I
just I I chew gum
I chew gum a lot like right there like
Zach
also one thing that I do have I bought I
think I brought this up before I bought
this massive like five pound bag of like
these they're hard candies but they're
like uh coffee flavor and I really
really like them and they're sweet but
they're not too sweet I think they're
only 10 15 calories each
and I sometimes if I'm sitting working
and I'm like God damn I'm so [ __ ]
hungry and then I'm like I'm just gonna
have one piece of coffee candy and I'll
pretend that that's food yeah so that's
what I do so I either do that or chew
gum yeah and then it doesn't really work
because I still get cranky but I don't
know it gets better like if you don't
eat much for several days like you get
used to it
you know I don't love it but
I've told you before like my [ __ ]
metabolism is molasses slow yeah so I
really have to kind of like
I have to keep it under 1200 calories a
day or I will be 400 pounds yeah and you
guys have to understand that Jenny is
enhanced she's not natural okay uh then
by the book she's slightly enhanced
she's on HRT
and she does
do little maintenance cycles of a lot of
it's some mostly wind straw
only at five milligrams a day for about
a month at a time which that can keep a
post-menopausal woman or a woman who's
beyond the age of [ __ ] 40 something
can keep her metabolism rolling forward
like a younger person and this applies
to men I mean I hit adrenopause which is
male menopause at around I don't know
late 40s
and I would never be built like this
without HRT
and uh I do maintenance Cycles also
uh
uh as you get older your body your
endocrine system just cannot produce the
hormones to give the signals to run the
cells the right way to burn food and to
burn fat and to keep your metabolism
running forward
uh
aging is not normal it's an error okay
you're falling apart so you you can
compensate slightly it costs money and
you have to know what you're doing but
once you get Beyond a certain age
you're not going to lose weight
unless you're on a [ __ ] starvation
the thing about it is that like I'm
doubly [ __ ] because my metabolism was
slow when I was young a kid yeah so you
know what I mean I'm one of those
[ __ ] it's just like I sniff a
cupcake and gain a pound you know what I
mean I'm one of those kind of people and
I've been like that and I've been like
that since puberty like I was skinny
when I was a kid
but as soon as I hit puberty 11 12 years
old I started chubbing out yeah and I
didn't eat all that much I didn't like
you know I ate like a southern kid but I
didn't like eat as much as like some
other people I see eating and I still
like just gained weight and gain weight
and so like I did like lose at one point
like 80 90 100 pounds but to do that I
had to eat
a thousand calories a day which like a
lot of people think it's oh that's not
enough and it's not it's not very much
food at all but if I eat any more than
that I will gain weight yeah Southerners
I've learned this over many years
American Southerners it doesn't even
really matter if you're white or black
we we survive famines people that had
fast metabolisms died okay this is
recent history
so we're all kind of
a true Southerner is kind of short
I mean I can go to these [ __ ] bars
around here and pick out people that's
old guys that are old southern blood and
younger Southern blood okay old southern
blood are all dudes under five eight
they're little short dudes they just are
they're just short because all because
in the Civil Civil War era era the
taller people will faster metabolisms
all starve to death
so you tend to be short
you tend to be real efficient no matter
what you eat you'll survive because
it'll stay it'll stick right yeah right
real right [ __ ] efficient metabolism
which like I said right in the modern
day not so not good but not so many days
if I was living during a famine sure
that would be great but I'm not so right
and then we tend towards diabetes which
that's the same as black people black
people too yeah my grandfather had
diabetes my dad is a borderline diabetes
right my grandfather had diabetes yeah
so we really got to watch sugar and
carbohydrates and how much you're eating
uh especially later on in life but
if you look at Southerners white or
black
when they're young they're short shapely
good looking
all right by the time there late 30s
they're short and fat
unless you [ __ ] through that two
things yeah
especially after children you know with
the women
well see that was maybe one thing that
saved me is I never had any kids yeah
now the thing about it like I said I was
skinny when I was a kid
I hit puberty about 11 or 12. like right
when I turned 12.
and then I started chubbing out yeah and
then though when I was in my mid-20s I
met my now ex-husband who was in he was
very thin and he was an athlete he was a
runner and a soccer player so I started
doing like Fitness [ __ ] like with him
and started eating better and stuff like
that so I actually like lost a lot of
weight like when I was in my 20s 30s
then like as time went on like in my 30s
I started gaining weight again and then
it's just kind of like then when I hit
about like 37 38 and you know me and my
husband were getting divorced I was like
okay well I gotta get this [ __ ]
weight off again so I went into
starvation mode I mean I went a thousand
calories and like yeah extreme like a
lot of exercise and I knew her that time
at that time she was chubby when I first
saw her star she was cute and chubby and
then it seemed like I came to the club I
knew her and her husband I came to the
club and she'd broken up with her
husband around that time and all of a
sudden I turned around and she was like
a hundred pounds
she was like 100 pounds and she looked
[ __ ] 20 years younger you look like a
[ __ ] 20 year old girl she looked
[ __ ] young I mean the thinnest I ever
got to was 118. got pictures of it yeah
I guess it was about 120. it was 118.
yeah it was the thing around that time
and at that point I kind of felt like
like I was into it but I was just kind
of like like a lot of people were like
you get a little bit too she was losing
weight while she was eating because once
the once that body once the ball once it
started it took a while to get it to
kick off and I was exercising too like
like a demon yeah so I was feeding her
to try to put a little bit more muscle
on her he kept saying you're too skinny
you're too skinny and he kept like and I
think like after we moved in together I
gained 30 pounds yeah because of your
food you looked better though you look
better at about around 140 pounds
my ideal weight is 135 yeah that's my
idea I have no idea what I weigh now but
my ideal weight is 135 that's why I feel
like because when I went down to 118
yeah
people started telling me you look kind
of [ __ ] up like you look kind of ill
you didn't look [ __ ] up it's just
people started thinking heavy shape yeah
people started thinking I looked you
need to look like some people said I
looked sick right and also I was
starting to have health problems like I
started having Health uh heart
palpitations and I started like passing
out yeah but the palpitations came from
the weight loss that wasn't that's what
I'm saying that's all that's what I'm
saying your your heart was used to
pumping blood through a much yeah
heavier body so that's another thing
like I lost a lot of weight in it was
five months right it was about five
months I think I lost about 90 pounds
you all know that I have a background on
all this [ __ ] I look at people just like
domestic animals and horses and [ __ ]
livestock that I worked with and [ __ ]
um
you would look best around 150 pounds
muscular
you know that's with a good muscle
composition
and fat on there to give it some shape
which is you're not really that far from
that but you know what I mean flicking
me I should weigh about a hundred and I
should weigh 195 to 200 pounds
but I should be about 15
between
10 and 15 body fat so I'm a few years
away from that at the rate that I'm
going
there's no way I could have ever
achieved these numbers
without HRT and androgenic assistance
because when you get Beyond adrenopause
or menopause if you're a woman
you just do not produce the hormones
required to hold a body together in that
shape because the hormones are what
what's making the is it is what's making
the
um your metabolism
work right and all at the even at the
cellular level to keep that shape it has
to do with things running well and as
you get older things don't run well
just like losing your teeth when your
teeth fall out you put in false teeth
when your hormones fall out just inject
the hormones it'll it'll grow back
that's all it is
um it's it's simple science by simple
science of biology the signals have to
be sent to the cells to get all that
[ __ ] done
it is not unhealthy that's a lie it's
healthy they got dudes that are doing
that with it what I'm doing at 73 years
old they look just like me at 73. you'd
never know what that dude was 73.
but he's doing things within certain
parameters you can't overdo things
the problem with exercise I have a flat
feet and there ain't much I can do about
that I have flat feet also
um this is why my preferred exercise is
bike
because
I did walking running stuff like that
when I was younger and it [ __ ] up my
feet and it [ __ ] up my knees uh but
bike is a lot better so I don't know if
that would work for you but I have the
same problems too I also have like super
super flat feet now I will chime in bike
is very good aerobics
problem with aerobics is that aerobics
is not concentrated
uh weight training it doesn't even have
to be very heavy just weight training
hour for hour pound per pound is far
more efficient
than Anna than aerobics
you should have aerobics
that's always great
aerobics does do things that she's had
results from aerobics
but when you're talking about
the reward for the amount of time that
was given she could have done that in a
fraction of the time with very small
weight training weight training is
better but you should have some aerobics
and this is very general not everybody
is exactly the same not all aerobic not
not all metabolisms are the same
and there's a big difference between
people who are natural and people who
are enhanced and Jenny and I are
enhanced
I mean I'm gonna be honest with you
people I'm 53 Jenny's what you're you're
all coming up on 50 right I'll be 50
next month most people RH don't look
like us
okay we go to the club
and uh girls that we knew as girls like
20 okay are saying you look a lot older
now and they're looking at us and
they're saying boy you guys just don't
age
it's not all natural
hormone replacement helps genetics was
part of it though too Jenny Jenny's mom
still looks young and she's in her 70s
you can tell that she's older but she
still kind of looks young but it's
because yeah we're the fat well and
honestly
um she got carded well into her 50s yeah
and my mother's side of the family was
[ __ ] Immortal all right my
grandparents on her side died recently
they lived well into their 90s mid 90s
all right on my dad's side they were
very my mom's mom is still alive she's
in her 90s right so there's really no
reason that what I'm doing now as long
as civilization holds together and I can
get what I need in terms of hormones and
testosterone and [ __ ] like that I should
live beyond a hundred I I probably lived
about 110 and I shouldn't look all that
old really my granddad on my mother's
side when he died at like 95 he didn't
look 95 he looked like he was
65 70 maybe you didn't look old
you know he didn't look like a [ __ ]
Crypt Keeper or anything
like a normal person but jeans is part
of it but hormones are really good yeah
because I mean I'm gonna be honest with
you some people I knew some people that
looked old when they were in their 30s
yeah
but sometimes
you get old like you reach that looking
old plateau and then you just look like
that for the next several decades yeah
I don't know but
yeah I don't know Danny Rose says what
do you do if your anus falls out and
becomes a pink sock then what do I do
go down and get stuff it back in there
you go ahead and get you a [ __ ] big
ass [ __ ] dildo something like called
Moby Dick or [ __ ] or or it's fine
Lube that [ __ ] up and push that [ __ ]
right back it's fine it's fine it
happens it happens yeah the [ __ ] sock
it's alarming yeah I get it but it
happens yeah I mean it's never happened
to me hopefully I don't really want it
to happen but I I understand that it
happens yeah
um Danny Rowling also said uh asking us
about
the movie Night of the Comet uh would
you ever review it I actually did want
to review it because I actually quite
like that movie have you ever seen that
of the Comet no it's like a
post-apocalyptic
post-apocalyptic valley girl oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah we gotta see that
again yeah that's their [ __ ] round in
the mall and they're like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh that's a good one
that's a David Jew said Patrick Stewart
looked old young up up in uh and didn't
age until like the last 10 years yeah
yeah I kind of yeah there's there's some
[ __ ] that like look young young
and then old but then there's like some
dudes that like look old when they're
like 22. yeah and but they look like
that for like 40 years Patrick Stewart
looked good he looked old but he looked
good for a long long time when I was
right he looked exactly the same yeah
when I was in high school when Dune came
out he looked old but he looked good as
[ __ ] what was his name Garney even in
[ __ ] even in uh the old Dune uh and
he he was good on on the old Star Trek I
heard that his new program [ __ ] sucks
but hold on to the restroom
yeah I'm always kind of like interested
about those actors that
looked like they were 40. like from the
time they were 19 or 20. and I
understand like people looked older back
then I would man oh I can't remember
what channel it was but I watched this
great video the other day
on YouTube about because this is
something I'd always wondered about too
he's like did people actually look older
back in the old days because when I used
to look when I was a kid I used to be
fascinated by my parents yearbooks
because they still had them like on the
bookshelf so I would go in there and
like look at them because I'd be like oh
look at my mom she was like so my mom
was adorable well like when she was in
high school and she looked young like
and my dad kind of looked young but I
noticed even when I was a kid that all
of these uh you know people that were in
this yearbook which was 1972 that's when
they uh graduated and that was also the
year that I was born uh so all of these
people like
eighty percent of them looked like they
were about 35 years old at least
and I don't know and I was always kind
of like would shut okay was that just
because people aged quicker back then or
was it because the haircuts or
I couldn't like really figure it out
so this guy like on YouTube did a video
like a whole video about that because
apparently that's a thing like people
wondering about like hey what the [ __ ]
like everybody back in the day
here's an example
if you guys are into Mystery Science
Theater they did a short called I think
it was called Is This Love or something
it was like or no it was are you what
are you ready for marriage that was it
and these two women that were in it were
supposed to be
in college and they were supposed to be
the same age
one of the girls okay I'll allow it she
looked like she was probably in her
early 20s
Other Woman looked like she was well she
looked older than me and I'm almost 50.
and she and I'm like I'm not buying that
as a college student so I was curious
and I looked up that actress uh like how
old was she actually like when she was
in that short 37. she was 37 and I was
just kind of like man that not to be
mean but that is a rough 37. I mean she
looked way older than I look right now
and
so that's always something that I always
kind of wondered about like people seem
like they looked older back then and I
think it's because I think it's
partially because I think a lot of it's
because one you know yeah the haircuts
and the Styles and stuff like that that
probably like age some people and he
made the point too that he's like well
people have a perception of like
clothing that people wear nowadays it's
like old people clothing but that's what
they were when they were young and
they're still wearing it now so we still
perceive it as old people clothing he's
like but also so that might be 50 of it
he's like but the other 50 is that
people are not exercising or eating the
way they eat now or they're not like
aware of like all the you know they're
not smoking or drinking or stuff like
that like people used to back then
that's what Danny said he said alcohol
and cigarettes right look uh out uh
cigarettes were much worse than alcohol
right much worse I smoked for a [ __ ]
oh man close to 20 years and I quit all
right I started vaping which helped me
quit I quit vaping cigarettes [ __ ] you
up worse and alcohol is not that bad for
you just as long as you keep it well I
mean you have to keep It Sane the modern
moderation as long as you're not
drinking and to Oblivion every [ __ ]
night but you know
in moderation it's not that bad for you
nowhere near as bad as cigarettes
cigarettes will [ __ ] you up well and you
have to think too it's not just like uh
the choices people were making they were
probably like eating you know not that
great and smoking and stuff but
environmental factors like there was a
lot worse pollution there was like all
that kind of stuff so that probably
without a cans that [ __ ] had lead in
it there was lead in the water that's
what I mean
probably asbestos there's a lot of
problems
probably didn't help but yeah I mean it
absolutely did I mean the fact that this
woman that was in the short That was
supposed to be a college student and I
thought
I was looking at her going that [ __ ]
looked like she's 55 years old and she's
like she was 37 I'm like but I mean
for back then I guess yeah that's about
what 37 looked like but I'm like she
looks way older than me now and I'm
almost 50. yeah they lived harder back
then I guess also uh there's something
about the photographic technology at the
time even in black and white it made
people look a little bit harder
um there's something about the because
it's reflected light on an image it's
only it's only hold on
it's only two colors
it's not a very Prismatic image
and there's a lot of contrast in it so
it made an image that was kind of hard
not very soft
so people looked even harder in in black
and white photos than they were but
like I said before
when you the movie prey
when I looked at those people that were
Native American dressed up as
old-fashioned engines all right
they looked just like regular modern
people
in Indian costumes and
there's something to be said for that
Carl Benjamin we talked about it
that lifestyle made you a lot tougher
than than an average middle upper middle
class person from California you know
what I mean they were living outside
they were hunting for food there was
caloric restrictions a lot of dietetic
limitations I mean they couldn't really
get large amounts of citrus fruit uh it
was a [ __ ] what mostly what we would
call today a keto diet they were eating
a lot of [ __ ] meat
um because that's what was there and uh
they would have looked different they
didn't look they wouldn't have looked
like little [ __ ] little college kids
in drama school they wouldn't look like
that yeah
they're actors well
you could have put them through a little
bit of a training program let them lose
a little bit of weight [ __ ] make them
hunt for their own food out in a [ __ ]
Wilderness before filming for about a
month or so it would have harder to
hardened them up pretty quick actually
because the Army did that kind of stuff
for us when we were becoming Infantry
uh you
train people to survive and it changes
you you know and that would have helped
a bit with the film and
that's why I was said earlier in another
program that Predator one was so
authentic feeling it's because it it was
that
that script was written by it infantry
guys ex-infentry guys who had fantasized
about that situation
and pretty much everybody in that in
that movie was military ex-military
um with the exception of probably Carl
Weathers I think Carl Weathers was an
ex-ball player which is real close
but already a lot of people forget Arnie
was in the Austrian Army he was attacked
he was a tanker which is combat arms
so he knew exactly that's why they
looked so good with those guns and so
natural the way they handled things
because that's what their old jobs were
when they were young you know they
weren't pretending to be soldiers they
were soldiers they were ex-soldiers so
that's one
even Paco Paco was [ __ ] uh the guy
who played Paco he was [ __ ]
ex-military Vietnam veterans and stuff
uh Shane was in it and he would do with
the glasses he was that he was actually
Vietnam
I'm not sure Sunny was ex-military he
might have been you guys would know I
think he probably was
and then uh you know
Blaine was uh who you know Jesse The
Body he was uh X and navy sealed I think
he was reserved but still he went
through a lot of that [ __ ] so so they
were very natural with these weapons and
that lifestyle they didn't have to act
that part they just went back into into
their job mode you know
and I think that kind of came across
they were able to focus on [ __ ] like
legendary epic tales about dudes trying
to get even and trying to atone for
their sins and you know which was that
was well you know that's what [ __ ]
Dylan was all about [ __ ] no I really
am a soldier I'm a soldier from the dark
side but we're still on the same team
and I'm gonna get these [ __ ]
because they killed my other team and
everybody had their own little
backstories and it all just that film is
a masterpiece definitely and it's better
than much better than Predator 2 even
though it's acceptable
movie but you can just tell the writing
the writing and the acting
you know even though I accept Predator
too it's okay that's good
than it has said all the preservatives
and the food are preserving our good
looks maybe yeah Jane said I remember
the old days of Tom vaping on the
audiopods yeah yeah yeah uh and Danny
rolling people complaining people
complaining about it yeah
guy says both my best friends in high
school Smoked Cigarettes heavily one had
heart attack and died insulin insulin
dependent diabetic one has had two heart
attacks yeah uh stent and quadruple
bypass and a stroke yeah so
I mean you well the thing about it you
smoked a lot longer than I did I
actually didn't start smoking until I
was in my 30s yeah and not gonna lie
every now and then like especially if
I'm kind of drunk or I'm out at the club
like if somebody offers me a cigarette
yeah why not but
other than that I never really like
think about it I started smoking at 15.
yeah you started much younger than I did
I didn't start till I was in my 30s like
I said I started smoking at about 15 and
stopped at about
40 42 right around 42 43. it says man I
gotta quit this [ __ ]
which is funny because
prior to that prior to discovering
vaping which actually got you to stop
smoking yeah
I think a year before you discovered
that you were like I don't want to stop
smoking I like smoking I was like a
heroin addict yeah I liked smoking I
liked it I still like it
but uh not anymore
I'd take a hit off a damn vape and I
[ __ ] love it and cough my ass off
because that was good though
okay but I don't I don't need any of
that I just walked away from it I feel
good feel good
um hopefully y'all [ __ ] you know
hopefully I dodge the [ __ ] cancer
bullet we'll see time will tell I had a
pretty tough Constitution and I wasn't
smoking super heavily my whole life
um so I think that might help well we'll
see although when I met you
you smoked a lot yeah
and that was one of the things that kind
of got me into smoking more because I
was like I had already started smoking
by that point yeah but hanging out with
you you were always smoking so I was
just kind of like yeah give me one of
those things it came and went over the
years yeah you know what I mean like it
it it eventually settled down to about a
pack a day
you know but when it was Heavy it might
have been a pack and a half to two packs
a day I would smoke two packs a day as a
kid I could smoke a [ __ ] on them yeah
they were cheaper then though
anyway you're young you could sure you
could shrug it off
yeah that's the thing like you can get
away with it for a long time yeah but
after a while it just it really starts
to catch up I had my long sex raid and
everything there's nothing there so I
guess I'm good we'll see I don't know if
it did any genetic damage
we'll know over time I must not give a
[ __ ] about smoking anymore because I do
kind of feel like I started smoking a
lot when I was going through a lot of
stress yeah and so that was like kind of
like it was very comforting but I don't
know I've been going through a lot of
stress lately because of like you know
work and money and all that kind of
stuff but I haven't really thought about
it and a matter of fact I haven't really
thought about smoking until somebody
just brought it up just now so we just
brought it up yes I call that Predator
one because to say Predator you also got
predators and the Predator so I'm making
sure everybody knows I'm just calling it
Predators well I'm pretty sure I mean
those are two completely different yeah
the Saturday says I was smoking those
herbal cigarettes I only smoked a few of
those herbal cigarettes while we were on
the show I smoked less than a pack of
those I got those at one point to see if
they were any better they're okay but
it's not really the same I probably
smoke 10 or 15 of those that's probably
every now and then like I said if I'm
this hadn't this hasn't happened for
probably like a year or more but like
every now and then like when I was out
of the club like I'd be super drunk and
like one of our friends that still
smokes like Angel or somebody like that
be like hey you want a cigarette or
somebody would have a clove or something
I'm like yeah okay but
you know and I would enjoy it but I
don't really I didn't think about it
otherwise and I still don't think about
it I got drunk over at mannequins one
time and went next door and bought one
of those packs of see a [ __ ] CBD
cigarettes they were [ __ ] horrible
though
I would smoke them but look at that [ __ ]
[ __ ] sucks never went back to him
that's the thing like the herbal ones
like
they're okay if you really kind of need
that but they don't it's not really the
same it's not the same they taste kind
of weird and I don't know yeah like I
said every now and then like a clove is
nice but it's all kind of like part of
the atmosphere when I'm at home
even if I'm stressed out I don't really
like think about it I don't really think
about it well it's almost about time for
me to go down there and cook something
to eat what you gonna make I don't know
you don't know I don't know well I don't
know what's down there uh what's down
there well I got some pork tenderloin
that was already cooked up I could make
some pork sandwiches I can make I got
some um
I can make actually I can make a pork
taco
uh I mean sandwich it's fine okay or
taco is fine or taco is fine I could do
either or
what else
we got any Burgers yeah I can do burgers
you want a hamburger well I mean are
they got some of those frozen are they a
thawed no but they don't have to be
I got their black their their Angus beef
[ __ ] hamburger patties I can [ __ ]
cook those
I don't know Burgers kind of something
okay I make a hamburger okay yeah I got
buns and everything Santa said spam I
got a [ __ ] ton of spam that's just
stashed around here for a [ __ ] a
month in case the world collab we were
kind of laughing about we forgot to
mention this on the misery show that's
right they talk about spam on misery on
the misery show because we just recorded
the review for it today yeah
she her secret to good Meatloaf was
grinding up spam and like putting in the
meatloaf into the hamburger into the
hamburger and I was like that's a good
idea
it's like gross but you know no I'm sure
it'd probably be all right they're
probably really good because I'm not a
big fan of spam but it was like mixed in
with like other stuff in a meatloaf then
yeah it's probably good because it's
very salty spam is nothing more than
than uh pork shoulder it's a good cut of
meat it is it's been salted the low
sodium would be even better if you were
to grind if you were to kind of grind
that up and mix that with with beef like
the hamburger
it'd be good it'd be like making sausage
all right yeah as long as you didn't
over salt like the rest of it you know
so yeah you gotta like compensate right
you mix in a bunch of egg with it and
and bread crumbs and uh some some uh
Worcestershire sauce and some uh ketchup
in there and you make a nice meatloaf
with it with some uh [ __ ]
uh minced onion or if I can diced onion
in there no that'd be great especially
if there's like diced pickle in it and
then uh bake it like that yeah that that
spam would yeah I mean like I said back
in 1990
um I get that they were like yeah she's
kind of like low class and she's goofing
on it yeah but nowadays I'm kind of like
that'd probably be all right yeah that'd
probably be better yeah because it would
season that meat
yeah and like I said you'd have to
compensate by under seasoning the rest
of the meat because spam is very very
salty but salty but if you go yeah you'd
want to do like a four to one ratio
that's what I'm saying like a four to
one ratio I'm saying well I'm gonna say
it still tastes like beef but it would
be be more like a beef sausage I told
you one of the good tips that I've
learned like from because for some
reason I'm like really fascinated by
these ladies that do these channels that
are like you know we're gonna like cook
it a whole entire gourmet meal like from
Dollar Tree or something like that so
I'm really into that one of the things
they do that's actually a really good
idea
um for cheapness and also for you know
just being like uh you know cheap with
seasoning and stuff like that they're
like you go to Dollar Tree or wherever
Dollar General and instead of getting
because you know beef is expensive
chicken's kind of expensive they're like
get those little chubs of sausage that
shit's already seasoned yeah in case you
don't have any season in your house and
it's like you can make that and like mix
it in with other stuff and you don't
really have to add any seasoning because
there's already a little seasoning in
there yeah uh and they're a lot like
cheaper than buying like regular meat so
a lot of them will buy those little
chubs of sausage that are already
seasoned and put them into recipes for a
while Goya was selling these
uh selling these little four packs of
chorizo in a [ __ ] plastic vacuum
packed bag they were good of Spanish
slash Mexican sausage they were red
and it just tastes like any other
sausage really it's not spicy
and it was great because they were kind
of almost like an MRE packaging for meat
and man that [ __ ] is so good I haven't
seen it in a long time though and it was
cheap when they first showed it it was
like an introductory price a pack of
four of those sausages it was probably
like 250. probably five bucks now
but that'd be great in white rice with
beans and stuff just dice it up and put
it in there it'd be [ __ ] delicious
well now I don't know about nowadays but
Dollar Tree apparently you can get these
little chubs of
you know about that big of the spice
sausage yeah for a buck or a buck 25.
yeah so they're like well that's already
like meat and it's already seasoned yeah
so you buy that for a buck or a buck 25
and you can mix in a spaghetti sauce or
you can like mix instead of like buying
expensive beef and like adding you know
spices and stuff like that they're like
it's way way cheaper what I got a dollar
store which is little packets of this
big of of Kraft cheese sauce in a
metallic bag and I was like man that's
like the cheese that's like cheese whiz
spread from the arm and they used to
give us they were only like a dollar
each so I got all four of them I bought
them out that was all they had and I was
like man this is going to go in my
rucksack for my bug out bag bag you can
spread [ __ ] this cheese sauce on
anything it was about the same size and
everything it was it it was craft
Cheese Sauce Cheese product cheese sauce
it's not cheese well no that's why they
call it like cheese product but it's
good for you
it's whey protein it's whey protein sure
it's equal to a meat and it's low
calorie high protein
um pretty low in fat actually and uh
with a good flavor it'll go with
anything it's good for you and it
they did a whole program on that show
somebody recommended the history of food
so that was it was great that shit's
over 100 years old and it was that was
such a good show yeah I think it might
have been Oracle though right craft came
up what they called American cheese
American quote quotation it's not cheese
it's bunny rabbit ears he was craft was
trying to figure out how to make cheese
how to make cheese last in your home
before refrigeration and he experimented
to experiment realized that cheese will
never last in your home without
Refrigeration so he came up with a
cheese-like product which is just like a
whey protein
flavored as cheese yeah and um it's not
cheese not under the definition of
cheese but it's a cheese-like product
and uh a whole slab of that [ __ ]
Velveeta cheese you could buy it cheap
and you it could stay outside without
Refrigeration just in a damn shelf in
your [ __ ] house for a month without
it going bad at least a month I would
still argue that the best application
application of Velveeta is that dip that
everybody made that you mixed Velveeta
and Rotel and ground beef if you're
feeling fancy grating an omelette an
omelets all the time it's [ __ ] great
hot although I'm not super into like if
I'm gonna eat an omelette I would rather
just be eggs and mushrooms like that you
know well yeah I told you before I don't
really like that Gloppy cheese in there
I'm just trying to give you some protein
then I don't really like I'm just trying
to give you something it's got protein
don't worry about it I'm not gonna die
more protein seriously I'm not gonna a
slice of that slice of that Crafter
Not Gonna Die can I please this can I
please just eat food that I like without
worrying about
I'm not gonna don't you shush me I'm
trying to tell them a slice of that will
be the cheese equal in size to say like
a slice of [ __ ]
chicken is equal to a slice of chicken
for per volume right but that's great
that's great but like I said my whole
thing is
I don't get to eat that much food yeah
so the food that I have I would like to
enjoy it but there's not much calories
in it well that's not what I'm saying
okay I'm just saying I would like to
enjoy my food so I don't really want
stuff that's just in there because
there's a disaster spam recipe sounded
good yeah it is that is that would be
good you guys like yeah spam like mixed
into meatloaf you know I got a jacket
that could work yeah that could work I
don't like really like spam by itself
like I said it's usually too salty eat
the low sodium it's like a little salty
for me yeah I'm not really real into it
yeah but if you mix it in with meatloaf
it'd probably be all right yeah yeah
xanada there was a
that what what that wasn't YouTube what
was it that was uh
no we watched that it was a whole series
yeah that series was on what
what channel was That on well we watched
it on it was on Hulu might have been on
Hulu I think we watched on Hulu history
of American food something like that
and it goes all the way back to the
1800s of where all this stuff come came
from
most of American food had to do with
serving large amounts of people over a
very large vast [ __ ] country
in an era before Refrigeration [ __ ]
tough
and then they talked about how difficult
refrigeration and freezing is it had to
do with bird's eye
yeah they did a whole show about
birthday and bird's eye I mean frozen
food that was like a big deal you would
think that it's easy to freeze food no
it is well nowadays yeah it is not easy
to freeze food back then not so much if
you were to freeze some food with the
methods that they had it destroyed it
every time you froze it when it thought
out it was just [ __ ] muck it has to
be frozen quickly
it has to be a flash Frozen
and then once it's frozen you could ship
it everywhere if you keep it frozen and
when it thaws it's edible
well that's why that was such a
fascinating show because I kind of feel
like maybe younger people nowadays like
take it for granted
you know the the technology has been
around for so long right now like
obviously we're gonna freeze it and
everything's fine yeah but back then
they didn't have that luxury so they had
to like come up with like some [ __ ] to
like work around it the one the the
person responsible for frozen food as
you know it was a woman and she was a
billionaire she inherited a [ __ ]
Empire and she invested in Bird's eye's
frozen food idea yeah she thought that
was like the best idea ever and she's
like um I can't remember now but she's
like yeah I'm gonna buy out your company
yeah and I'm gonna help this [ __ ]
dream come true because she like thought
hey this is like the future right and
people wouldn't buy freezers so what she
did was she had freezes constructed in
all these stores across the Across
America ready for this frozen food to
arrive
okay people didn't even have freezers in
the house they would just buy it frozen
take it home put it in the icebox and
maybe like a day or so later or that
night then they cook it yeah you cook
that's how they did it and then later on
the refrigerator the refrigerator
appeared and it had a freezer in it that
took time that took I mean we have it so
easy now yeah you have right like
nowadays not only do we have
refrigerators freezer all that stuff but
honestly you can go to like uh a myriad
of websites right and they will deliver
food to your house that's already
portioned all you got to do is like
[ __ ] put it in the in the [ __ ] in the
air fryer and it's done right I mean
it's so easy yeah telecommunications was
a dream that could have never been
around here that time they didn't have
telecommunications as you knew it like
being able to place up an order on your
tablet or on your phone and have
something delivered to your house that
could have never like I said you could
have entire like [ __ ] groceries and
like I said there's a whole
I mean you can go to like places like
butcher box or like uh green Chef or
like places like that that will just
like bring you right already portioned
like ingredients and all the recipe
cards and everything like that like hey
here's five seven you know a whole month
worth of dinners right here's another
thing you all [ __ ] take take it for
granted being able to pay for something
online by the touch of a [ __ ] button
when I was a little kid they didn't I
love it they didn't even have ATM cards
and a credit card only rich people had
that and then that was some [ __ ] they
had to [ __ ] I was gonna say it back and
I remember when I was a kid yeah
yeah you sound like old people yeah we
are old people we are old people but I
do remember that I mean I was a kid uh
when they had the whole credit card like
yeah with the carbon but
I still remember that though right an
online banking back in when I was a kid
was you had an ATM card you had to go to
the bank and go on the outside and
withdraw all the cash and then you're
still cat it's still cash
but it's just [ __ ] funny you couldn't
take you couldn't take your ATM card and
pay for what you bought at Denny's that
didn't work you had to go to the [ __ ]
bank and get cash and get the cash I
guess yeah there's a difference this is
a big pain Camp guy said my grandfather
used to send telegrams with Morse code
in the 1930s yeah he was a clerk in the
little yeah and that's what you don't
like even in people that are still alive
like in their living memory yeah there
was [ __ ] like that going on yeah I can't
imagine what it must be like to have
grown up in the 20s and 30s and like be
dealing with [ __ ] now well we got
grafters online he's I think he's a ham
radio operator [ __ ] I turn on my hand
radios at certain times [ __ ]
listening through a repeater and I'll
hear Morris code coming through the
repeater and I go man I know that that's
some old [ __ ] fat old
[ __ ] nerd out there [ __ ]
doing Morse codes and he's just saying
good night people see you tomorrow let's
see if anybody knows
editor and it's just funny yeah they're
still [ __ ] sending Morse code more
the reason why you use Morse code in the
modern era uh over radio is that the
morse code doesn't require much
energy and with a small amount of
transmission power you can reach the
other side of the damn planet with Morse
code Morse code is the [ __ ] but it's
totally obsolete toilet if people
understand it then you know but how many
people understand it still now it's
hobbyist [ __ ] okay but the thing is is
uh as a guy who [ __ ] wants to cover
his own ass it is good to know about ham
and Morse code because if there was ever
something like a solar flare that would
[ __ ] a wipe or an EMP strike
all the [ __ ] internet and cell phones
will all be gone but they'll it'll go
right back to 1800s technology which is
[ __ ] radio Morse code then all the
Nerds would be like yeah Vindicated she
told you [ __ ] making money sending
messages you guys made fun of me for
doing Morse code but Who's Laughing Now
Who's Laughing Now [ __ ] Morris is
back yeah they could do it just by
earlier
somebody else says something back and
it's they're probably cussing at each
other because if you listen to the audio
Transmissions the same ham
guys are talking about the [ __ ] to
talk about the weather and talk about
radios
you know but it's still good to know
still good enough for local
Communications if I'm down there [ __ ]
mowing I can give Jenny one of my
[ __ ] gmrs or [ __ ] hams or whatever
man come bring me something to drink you
know it's just you know what I mean I'm
mowing the lawn I need some yeah I need
some water yeah or some booze but I had
two little two little GMS gym gmrs
radios which don't require a ham license
there's a little bitty short antennas
and I wanted to see how far they
transmit I gave Jenny one with a little
four inch antenna and the other one was
a two inch [ __ ] antenna it was all
coiled up as an expensive little antenna
and I walked all the way down the block
that was probably about a quarter of a
mile one third of a mile and I could
hear it clearly that's that's good
little thing for you know only 20 bucks
20 something bucks per radio
yeah they got good [ __ ] nowadays they
got good [ __ ] I don't want to go back to
the old days they didn't have they had
batteries they didn't have anything yeah
they were they were uh in case you guys
wanted to know they were about Faye uv9
uh G's is what they were and I got the
uv9r also good little radios getting
about 30 bucks each depending on what it
is
all right so let's eat yeah we've been
going for three and a half hours yeah
and we covered the case I'm amazed that
I'm still awake I guess the alcohol
helped yeah okay I told you 5 30. Pookie
woke me up running up and down the Halls
like a crazy person
so all right so we're gonna wrap it up
so come back Friday night for our Side
Tracks show uh that should be fun
actually tomorrow night I think we're
gonna go to riftrax live so maybe I'll
talk about that a little bit if it's
good uh so yeah thank you everybody for
dropping by this evening thank you for
your super chats uh very generous this
evening which we always appreciate and
we will see you guys again on Friday
evening for Side Tracks and good night